yo what a day we got uh that footage
from the Memphis cops the horrific video
of five officers reigning punches on
Tyree Nichols as he screams out mom mom
before dying in the hospital after
cardiac arrest and kidney failure and
the video's pretty brutal yeah I haven't
I haven't seen all the different angles
but I see these cops holding a guy with
his hands behind his back and they're
just going at his face like crazy it's a
brutal video
so uh protests have already begun people
are concerned about violent riots even
though they already fired and arrested
the cops involved they're still going
out and protesting I don't know what
they're protesting for because they've
like you got what you wanted I mean you
wanted the cops brought to Justice I
mean they're they're going to go to jail
probably we'll see and then we got the
Pelosi footage getting released and I've
got a I'll call it a correction I said
that I think that I I think I thought it
was likely in my 4 P.M segment that this
may be a drug deal gone wrong I'm not
saying I know for a fact I'm just saying
it sounds like it might make more sense
and I missed that they released the
backdoor footage of him smashing the
windows out I still think there's a lot
of questions that need to be asked about
how weird this video is like why Paul
Pelosi is holding a drink as the door
opens why he doesn't then go out to the
cops while he then grabs the hammer but
doesn't drop his drink to grab the
hammer I just it's a very weird thing
very very weird the 911 calls weird a
lot of people are saying guys it's just
de-escalation he was trying to stop a
crazy crackhead from attacking him
Maybe
maybe but I do kind of feel like saying
to Pap is crazy is a weird catch-all for
all of the unexplainable things that we
think are weird right it's just like oh
the the reason why uh he was holding
that glass he was he escalated because
the perhaps crazy the reason the pap was
there crazy the reason to perhaps
sitting with him letting him call 9-1-1
crazy I just I just find that kind of
weird so we'll talk about that plus I've
got a bunch of other stories before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work click that join us button as a
member you are funding the operation
that is timcast your membership helps
this show exist our other shows and all
the work we do exist and you'll also get
access to members only shows Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM a massive
library of content go check it out it's
really great stuff we had a bunch of
awesome guests this week and uh I want
to I want to just shout out the event
you can see right here in Austin sold
out
sold out two shout outs it's gone it's
sold out I can't believe it I mean I
guess I can believe it we got Alex Jones
Blair white lukerkowski Alex Stein
Michael Mouse this is going to be one
Awesome event and there were only 300
tickets to begin with so those sold out
in like two days yeah totally man but
it's gonna be fun maybe we'll figure out
a way to do similar things more so that
and different you know it's hard to
travel it's hard to set up a show on
stage and do all this stuff but uh thank
you to everybody who bought tickets so
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
Aiden Kearney what's happening Tim
thanks for having me yeah who are you uh
so my name is Aiden Carney although they
just call me turtle boy around New
England I run a media entity called
Turtle Boy Daily News we've broken
hundreds of stories uh that the
mainstream media won't touch because we
go after powerful people that the rest
of the media is afraid to go after uh
but for that reason I've been
de-platformed I've been I've had over 50
Facebook pages taken down I've been
banned from Twitter for two years I
can't use PayPal GoFundMe or venmo
um I've been sued dozens of times
undefeated in court like to point that
out including a most recent Boston City
councilor is currently suing me for
writing about her alleged uh drinking
and driving incident so basically this
is what I do um the Main Street some
when the mainstream media does cover our
stories frequently they like to steal it
without attribution in particular Andy
Noe seems to have a thing for my content
uh and uh yeah so that's basically what
I do well right on thanks for thanks for
joining us we also got Hannah Claire
hanging out hi I'm Hannah Claire I'm a
writer for timcast.com
hey hi Hannah hi Claire not Hannah oh
thanks for having me
um I want to Echo something James
O'Keefe said last night in a Twitter uh
in a Twitter space that he hosted after
IRL up until midnight Eastern that we
are the media now we are the mainstream
media and this Legacy stuff they're not
the mainstream anymore it's fed to
people via television no one cares I
mean it's very very low compared to
stuff like this compared to getting 20
million views on the Veritas video
yesterday that is the mainstream in in
the Consciousness and I'm happy to be a
part of it and I wanted to mention two
things before we get started one I start
the last few days with bucko the cat Mr
bocus and we traveled across country to
a stem cell Clinic that was able to
harvest some of his fat cells they
thought we didn't they didn't get enough
fat he called me today and told me your
cat's a rock star somehow out of six
grams of fat they got as many stem cells
out of what they could get out of 150
grams of fat from a dog and he was he
was shocked almost in shock at how met
how well bucko did
um thank you Bucko for for keeping
positive I don't know if there's some
sort of entanglement going on in your
cells over there doing well because
you're doing well over here or no no
it's it's all the people who have
watched and have prayed for Mr boat it's
it really cellular life is attuned to
the vibration of your soul so keep it up
and I I just want to say like I I
have to wonder about that you know we we
repeatedly talk on the show about our
cat Mr bocus and how he's sick and he
doesn't have much time to live
and now the doctor's saying it's a
miracle we were able to get enough stem
cells out of here's almost no fit and he
was able to pull it off I I wonder if
it's all the people who've been praying
for me I think it's something he didn't
say Miracle doctor he's a miracle yeah
doctors maybe stay a little more
scientific and he pointed out that it
was um oh mental fat from bucko whereas
150 grams of the dog was falsiform fat
so they're different kinds of fat too
which might have something to do with it
but he was still he was still taken
aback and very happy about it and then
secondly you know I love graphene so I
put my money where my mouth is and I got
a shirt made out of graphene literally
the shirt and the pants if you can see
are made out of 90 graphene uh woven
polyester it's the graphene is infused
with the polyester and then it's 10
Spandex and it feels cool we've got to
make Ian's graphene Darkness freaking do
it man because it's like heat absorbent
but it's also cool to the touch I like
it yeah everyone's saying you need a
graphene dark roast for the coffee
company yeah
yeah we'll have to do it get the
hexagons on the on the package maybe
we'll do like an espresso roast and
it'll be like Ian's graphene espresso I
love it I'm in all right we got search
pressing the buttons yo what's up guys
uh glad to have you back again thank you
it's been fun without you but we're
we're really missing you out here thank
you anyways let's get started all right
here's the first story we got from The
Daily Mail breaking news Memphis cops
release horrific video five officers
reigning punches and kicks down on Tyree
Nichols is that it pronounce it Tyree
Nichols I was calling him Tire nickels
before I couldn't tell
because like if it was Tyree I think
it'd be like two e's but I'm not trying
to get his name wrong let's say Tyree as
he screams out mama before dying in
hospital after cardiac arrest and kidney
failure so
they got a bunch of different angles
they pepper spray them they pin them on
the ground there's surveillance footage
where he's got his hands behind his back
they're holding I think they've cuffed
him at this point right yeah I think so
and then the cop just walks up and just
does full boom boom just starts wailing
you see him going back and forth yo it's
tough to watch yeah it's very tough to
watch and they had that uh that doc I'm
sorry the chief of police came out
earlier and said it's as worse or as bad
or worse than Rodney King and so I'm
kind of just like yo do they want people
to Riot tonight because they want the
riots because they want they've been
hyping it up all week and then she's
like we wanted to release the footage on
a Friday when no one was in school or at
work so it wouldn't be disruptive it's
just like so you want to make sure
everyone is available in the protest to
Riot exactly they did the Mike Brown
non-indictment announcement on a Friday
night too if I recall it's like right at
this exact time it's it's like they want
people to Riot yeah I think they do that
there was that uh the fire bomber the
antifa fire bomber in New York one year
in prison the judge even praised the
dude the judge was like you're a good
guy you know you've done a lot of great
things you're going to go far away for a
year and it's just like this guy
firebombed a police vehicle and him and
his friend were giving out fire bombs
and one year meanwhile some like Bumble
and Bumpkin walks into the Capitol
Building confused and you're like 20
years in prison I'm exaggerating by the
way but like you know they that Viking
man got four that's a good who did
viking man got for it all right he's
like he was a guy who's just like
doofing about he didn't do anything yeah
he just trespass four years in prison
meanwhile fire bomber welcome to America
we can have a I mean we were talking
about the other day like are we in for
another Summer of Love it's like it's
still winter man I'm kind of feeling
like summer Love's coming it seems like
it I could go for an actual Summer of
Love at this point how about you guys
what does that mean like where we
actually love each other again trying to
take care of each other I mean I'm not
down with violence though you break
something you buy it man you wreck
somebody's house you're you're
threatening their livelihood in their
life at that point we talked about this
the other day I think I don't know if we
talked about on the show but uh we're
talking about how property rights are uh
life rights like the root of property
rights is your ability to live safely
and securely that's why you can own land
and you can farm and grow food if if you
are like I am going to work all year to
grow food and then some Communists
jumping they're like it's not yours it's
ours well then nobody has security and
if they kick you out of your house if
they if they burn your house down you go
out in the and it's cold outside you'll
die from hypothermia like there's no
juice no joke your home is your is the
is the central Nexus of your livelihood
now I did the unthinkable today I
watched a lot of MSNBC and CNN just to
kind of see you just see what everyone
well it's like all they're talking about
is this this one person and him dying
and and it's almost like they're just
feeding into it they're making the seem
like this is the biggest story in the
country when in fact it's one of
thousands of murders that happen every
month in this country like that's what
like if this worst case scenario these
cops did it they murdered them they're
like you said I think they did they're
already in jail like these videos what
else do you want besides them getting
arrested like what are you protesting
for protesting is
that's exactly what it is but they're
not saying that but that like so when
when Biden gets out there and he said he
actually said like we want you to
protest peacefully why are you
protesting at all protesting what they
were already arrested they're in jail
what else do you want but yeah exactly
this is it that they they know that
abolish the police is unpopular but
that's really what they want you got a
video I gotta say like I watched the
surveillance footage and I'm just like
yeah there's no justification for having
a guy in cuffs who's just standing there
and then you start wailing on his face
yeah always bad yeah it was
uncomfortable I haven't seen the video
is it too graphic I don't think we can
play it on YouTube so was he saying
something and then they came up behind
him you said too much kind of thing no
like he was like he was dizzy
disoriented they just kept hitting him
like and it seemed almost personal like
very personal like I'm sure there's more
to it well Cindy you didn't deserve it
don't get me wrong but it seemed like
the either the cop has roid issues or
something something wrong with that guy
well I'll just say I probably probably
shouldn't say it but I want to you're
talking about the Super Chat the Super
Chat where someone said there's a rumor
that he was banging a dude's wife or
something like that yeah more than it
was personally yeah but but I only say
that because you said it looked like it
was personal and I felt the exact same
way like when they got the deuce of guy
subdued and then the dude walks up and
just winds up and goes boom boom I'm
like does he know that guy right because
that's not I like all the videos we've
seen of cops when they're like detaining
or arresting someone you can tell what
they're doing and why they're doing it
like a lot of these videos are stop
resisting and then they start hitting
him and punching him in the head but
that's like they call it pain compliance
this looks like Revenge yeah it's like
that one guy in particular it's not like
yeah yeah what you're doing it yup he
looked like in Mortal Kombat when it's
like you finish him yeah that's what he
looked like so that one cop was the one
who kept yeah it was only the one cop
and I know there was one uh I don't know
if there was also a part of it where
they're hitting with an eye stick I
don't know if that was like the same cop
or whatever you know it could be that
this rumor emerges because people people
are like does this guy know him yeah you
know it's a good point they're trying to
fill in the gaps I mean Memphis is like
one of the most violent cities in the
country and so if we were trying to have
a hotbed for cultivating
um an anti-police sentiment it might be
one of the places to do so because I'm
sure there are a lot of people there who
feel as though the justice system is
against them and you know hurts everyone
they know I think it's the obvious
parallels you're going to see here that
you know this man was stopped uh it was
it started as a traffic stop and there
are cities like Philadelphia that have
tried to do away they try to get rid of
any chance of having a traffic stop to
avoid this kind of Confrontation or a
confrontation escalating uh the video is
I mean I think the video speaks for
itself but obviously if we find out
later that there is some sort of social
or relationship some sort of connection
between the men like I don't think it
makes it better I think it's just it
probably speaks to more systematic
issues in Memphis yeah it could even
indicate like premeditation the guy
knows the guy and he sees him across and
he walks towards him to hit him that
that's very different than he's on him
and then he starts hitting him yeah at a
defense or or something it's just hard
to like I don't think that's true that
the guy was banging his wife I think it
just sounds Sensational it was a super
chat so yeah he's on the internet
must have some value if it's on the
internet I don't know maybe we should
they paid to say that so maybe I just
Google it I'll see
so then what happened these five cops
are in jail right now because this is
like the person they all turn themselves
in and they've all been they've been
arrested but I think they all posted
Bond last I read were they actually are
they out I think they're out but then
again
I wonder where they are right now
because it sounds like Memphis is not
the place to be is there riots right now
it I mean I don't know about right now
but it seems like there's a chance that
tonight isn't a night for it yeah I mean
Colin was watching footage I don't know
where he was watching but there's
definitely people out on the streets
there are demonstrations but I don't
know if it's escorts oh yeah yeah this
this there's like a YouTube video from a
day ago was Tyree Nichols having an
affair with one of the officers wives
and they found him and they were like
so I typed in so I picked up Google I
typed in Tyree Nichols and it auto felt
it Affair Reddit and I was like whoa
what so I clicked it and just gave me a
bunch of Reddit posts about the story so
I got rid of Reddit so it says tyrannos
Affair and there's a video where a guy
sang it from yesterday so maybe it was
someone just speculating I don't know
because people are trying to people like
why would the cops do this is like is
the cop just a murderer and he was just
feeling like killing a guy or was there
a reason for it
it's pretty rare I think most murder I
don't know I don't actually have the
data to back this but most murder is
between people that know each other is
that true and I think a lot of the cops
are just uh they see
the mental aspect of being a cop like
they see dead bodies all the time like
they come across a car accident they see
they're the first to see a dead body
they have to call People's loved ones
these people a lot of police I think are
suffering from mental health issues and
they're messed up in the head what I saw
in that video I mean that's that man has
serious issues like anger issues he's
probably seen a lot of things Memphis is
a dangerous cities working a lot of
dangerous areas and I'm not justifying
anything he did obviously he needs to be
held responsible for that but what you
saw in that video is not normal anger an
accountant doesn't have that kind of
anger in them somebody that actually
sees crazy on a daily basis like
that's what I saw in that video so
what's your prescription are we going to
get a Summer of Love
oh yeah we're gonna I mean well luckily
it's winter so we got that going I mean
look look this stuff's already starting
in January I mean normally we wait until
the springtime when people start coming
out but people are protesting in Winter
which
you know it's almost like the groundhog
see his shadow like did the protesters
come out in winter because if they do
then they're then they're heated up
yeah it's a lot of it I think is
desperation with this economic downturn
I'm really we need some sort of like uh
industrial Revival or revolution in this
country but like why do we know but like
so one guy in in Memphis was murdered
right so but people are murdered across
the country on a daily basis and this is
what annoys me about this is that this
is what the media and politicians
Democratic politicians tell us is
important this is the biggest story but
it's really not because people get
murdered every day in this country in
Massachusetts the other day I don't know
if you guys heard about this yeah one of
the most horrible stories I've ever
heard a mother
um a nurse a delivery nurse at Mass
General Hospital murdered her three
children or I saw the story and and then
tried to kill herself by jumping out of
the window to me that is so much of a
bigger story than this because the
problem that caused her to do that is
mental health and that isn't something
that we are not right but you don't
protest that right but why aren't like
you never hear calls to like let's do
something about the mental health system
here's my plan to fix the mental health
system so many people are dying in this
country every year because of mental
health that's an actual problem that is
a solution that can be fixed whereas
what are these people trying to fix
they're already in jail there's not a
problem to be fixed here five bad cops
did something bad and they're being held
they look at the police and say the this
is going to keep happening so long as
you have a police department and with
the women killing their kids people are
going to be like what should we do yeah
you make a good point a lot of the mass
shootings are people that have are on
psychiatric some sort of psychoactive
drug and uh and what's the first thing
they try to do after they'll try and ban
guns gonna take away guns instead of go
at the pharmaceutical companies that are
profiting off of shoving drugs down
people's throats instead of fixing their
diets and you know it's like the thing
about demonizing police is it stresses
out the people that are on the force the
police force and then when they're out
there they're more stressed and then
they become more likely to get agitated
on the job so like or or fearful
resulting in an escalation of force
absolutely you know hating thing that is
not going to make these people fight
less right I think they see defund the
police as like a very simple solution
right cops are killing people if we get
rid of them those are gone and I think
it becomes harder to talk about mental
health like I think I think you're
totally right mental health would should
be a a bigger push in this country and
in fact what when you start talking it
made me think of there's a wave of
different families over the Christmas
time who were all involved in murder
suicides right like these very large
families I think they're two in Utah but
mental health is more complicated right
you mentioned diet we could talk about
medication we could talk about
environmental stress like it's much
harder to pinpoint a fix on one thing
whereas if I say well if cops killed
someone we should just get rid of all
cops it becomes much easier for people
to all jump on board it's not that I
advocate for that solution it's just
that like it's it markets itself better
you know what I mean and so even though
it's misdirected I think it's much
easier to push people towards that cause
or that that effort now I just want to
point out uh all these cops that got
arrested they were all black so does
that remove the racial component do you
read van Jones today what do you say oh
he said that his white uh it's
internalized white supremacy you got to
see the headline I screenshot it uh
somewhere you would think it satire but
it's actually real life I think it was
the guardian had one though I think the
guardian here's the headline and um
opinion the police who killed Tyree
Nichols were black but they still might
have been driven by reason oh come on
man like CNN I know I got it right here
and I'm trying to be like I'm trying to
be like can we can we point out that
there the protesters are angry with the
policing system and it's not just a race
thing and no they can't they can't help
it they can't they're they're opponent
Clayton Bixby it's it's a it's a Dave
Chappelle Clayton Bixby yeah literally
like how do they not laugh
these are uh you know three adult black
males and I just pointed out to him I
was like you know it's funny is it
because your guy says politics you're
all white supremacists but Serge over
here is African-American because he's
from South Africa quite literally it's
just like the logic yeah right like Elon
exactly Luke Luke is uh lukerkowski's
Polish person of color so that makes him
a person of color how come uh Slavs are
considered people of color I always
wonder about Portuguese according to
wokeness because the woke don't believe
white means your skin color it means
political like dominant force or
something and because ukrainians Polish
people or whatever and like Romanians
are in like a worse off economic
position right the blonde hair blue-eyed
Lou gradkowski according to the
Coalition for communities of color they
say he is a person of color now I see a
through line here because they say and
they say hotep Jesus a black man is a
white Supreme
whiteness and the patriarchy are kind of
hand in hand I do believe it comes from
the Roman slave state it was essentially
the Romans were racist genocidal Maniacs
that would conquer and murder and
enslave other people that weren't pure
blood Roman they were like the Nazis of
the time if the Nazis had won and
conquered the half the planet
yeah it wasn't just the Romans but the
Roman patriarchy the Roman the church
that they created like has done such
damage in the amount of slavery that
they imposed on people and and it still
is like bled through into our society we
have like white Roman Heritage but it's
like it's not the skin color that's
where we that's where it exactly it
starts to get blurry we gotta look past
the skin color and look at the actual
patriarchy the we even call ourselves
Patriots like that's a male dominant
thing they say God is a man that's male
dominant crap it doesn't have to be like
that you know he's going full feminist
yeah I was gonna say I don't think I
agree with you no one you don't have to
well no it's okay I think part of this I
think it's easy to say like oh it's one
one group that had this terrible system
but like let's remember that when the
Romans had slaves so did tons of other
people right like we are saying that oh
because we are tied to Romans and they
had slavery therefore this through line
is there but that's not true because
you'd have to say it for all
civilizations right and every descendant
of a culture that had slave would in
that idea have the same fault right I
think when we talk about patriarchal
culture uh it becomes easy to again say
that there is one problem right that men
are too aggressive and that men don't do
this and whatever and I I think that's
not true personally right I think that
there are faults with some Patriot
dominated societies but I don't think
being tied to your heritage and
typically Heritage is traced through the
masculine line of your family is bad
right I think we have a better
understanding of our history and again
typically that's tied through the male
dominated line you have a better way of
looking at the faults in your culture
right it becomes more difficult to
reflect on yourself when you are
divorced from
so this is the this is from Van Jones on
CNN the police who killed Tyree Nichols
were black but they might still have
been driven by racism it's just what
he's the same one at CNN he's the one
that occasionally you're like oh van
Jones said something I agree with you
right occasionally three decades ago
when four white LA police officers were
videotaped beating Rodney King the
public outcry was heard around the world
in fact I got arrested for the first
time in my life during protests that
followed and I subsequently dedicated my
career as a lawyer to helping to sue
Rogue cops closed prisons and reform the
criminal justice system
what happened to gang was horrifying he
then goes into mention but at least he
survived Tyree Nichols did not yada yada
five former Memphis police officers
fired for their elected actions during
Nichols versus a legend is a video of it
have now been indicted I was in law
enforcement during the Rodney King
incidents as a chief by all accounts he
was good how do we explain Nichol's
horrific killing alleged the hands of
police who looked like him from the King
beating to the murder nearly three three
years ago of George Floyd blah blah blah
blah how do we explain it it's extract
people are not immune to anti-black
messages one of the sad facts about
anti-black racism is that black people
ourselves are not immune to its
pernicious effects at this point I just
want to give a round of applause to Van
Jones at for this sophistry at um coming
up with a reason why these black cops
were actually anti-black racists for
beating up another black man it's not
just him though it's like Jameel uh Hill
like this was a common take on Twitter
today about this like as soon as they
saw that picture where all five cops are
black you're like well now we've got to
go to plan B like the original the
original plan was racism well like well
now we're gonna have to explain this a
little more what look what look what
they did with Zimmerman remember they
were like a white man it's like
Zimmerman's Hispanic I don't know if
he's Mexican he's Cuban I think Cuban
there you go and they were like well
he's a white hispanic yeah what does
that mean are you kidding me what I'm
getting is Van Jones is suggesting that
these do these five cops were serving
the white master and doing its bidding
exactly but it's just so it's not a
white and black thing this is what
drives me nuts man yeah there are
corporate Overlord there are people with
power but I mean maybe maybe I'm blind
and that there really is a racial thing
like they they annihilated the Native
Americans they were like they're Savages
they didn't consider them human like
they were just killing anything that
wasn't white or whatever at the time
they had black slaves listen listen
listen there's a reason why these things
emerge in human civilization
you live in a small village of 100
people
everybody's Orange
you know that when you see a person and
they're orange you're like oh they
probably live in my Village I can I can
trust that and feel safe
100 miles away there's a village where
everybody's green
one day you come across a green person
you're like that I've never seen that
person before I don't know who that is
they're not from my Village that's a
threat that's dangerous so over time as
humans are coming closer and closer
together we start living with people of
other with different backgrounds
different heights different skin colors
we start to go like oh you know that
didn't matter at all we we we're now
humans and so over time we start to
actually move away from this from from a
lot of this in the United States in a
bunch of other countries they don't so
you end up with yes race is often an
issue even in the United States people
racially profile even Mike Bloomberg
went on about how he does this and then
you end up with like I can understand to
a certain degree what van Jones is
saying but they're taking in a direction
that I think is disingenuous
there have been black cops who in on
numerous occasions have been seen
arresting and beating young black men
and then the woke activists try and
claim like oh the police did this and
it's white supremacy and it's racist and
then when you point out like hey I don't
think the race was the issue if the cops
themselves were black I think it's a
these guys are in a high crime
neighborhood they're black the people
who live there are black and the cops
are concerned about the level of crime I
don't think the black cop is looking at
the black kid and being like he looks
like me like what's he thinking
therefore this guy's more dangerous no I
think what it is is it doesn't matter if
you're white doesn't matter if you're
black it matters if they're like hey
we're sending you to a crime scene and
you're like okay
now you're going to be on edge and be
like I'm in a dangerous neighborhood I
think I feel like
what you're saying makes me think of all
of
diversity and
there are a lot of police stations are
police departments across the country
that specifically we're like we want to
make sure our Force represents the
people that they're policing right they
are of the same racial makeup they are
related to the community they have a
better way to relate to them like if I
don't know if Memphis has this policy in
place but if they do does this tell us
that like that doesn't matter that
people who are prone to be cruel and
violent will do it no matter who they're
looking at imagine if these guys were
like diversity hires like imagine that
like you know like like this is part of
the diversity equity and inclusion they
hire these guys but maybe I mean we I
remember there's a lawsuit I think it
was out of New York where they
purposefully hire stupid people to be
cops and they said it's because they
hire smart people they get bored they
quit and that that's that's their excuse
but you hire people of low quality
you're going to get low quality output
you know interesting do you guys
remember I I'm just totally gonna bring
this up do you remember when Ben and
Jerry's tweeted about this what is it
called the third the 1350
there are a bunch of people who they
were even posting this the other uh the
other day we were we were talking about
uh with Nuance Pro crime in Democrat
cities and he mentioned the racial
disparity in crime and all that stuff
and I'm like I think there's a lot to do
with history poverty and then we look at
the surface level or I shouldn't say we
but a lot of people and they're like hey
I noticed a lot of crime in this
community and they tend to be this race
or that race and it's also like yeah but
there's a lot more context there that we
need to bring up I'm not saying race
plays no issue or anything I'm just
saying historical uh like slavery
generational wealth poverty lack of
Education these things play a much much
bigger role in my opinion than anything
else but Ben Jerry's this is a really
important point because the woke people
do this and that's exactly what this is
Ben and Jerry's posted on Twitter
something like
you know uh the African-American
Community is only 13 of the US
population but they comprise something
like you know 50 percent of prison
inmates and I'm like that's the same
meme that you'll see you know uh people
post on the internet that I don't want
to say every single person to post that
is a racist but are associated with
being the right or racist the left
believes the exact same thing yeah yeah
they they the left want segregation
the left is blaming racism
anti-blackness on why black cops
attacked a black man because they can't
help but view the entire world through
the lens of race
it's it's the woke law of projection you
have a white liberal who is extremely
racist who then says you know what
you're racist too and you're like me I'm
not racist and like yes you are the
reason they're saying that is because
they think everyone must think the same
thing they do they can't imagine that
other people have different beliefs it's
a cult so
everybody projects everybody thinks the
way I view the world is the way everyone
else views the world no I shouldn't say
everybody there's a lot of people who
understand that they don't probably tend
to watch shows like this or Crowder or
six exam or even bars like to be on the
opposite side of the wokeness but these
woke people very much so are racist
and then project thinking if I think
this way so must everyone else then they
go to you and tell you you're racist and
no matter what you say they won't
believe you because you must think well
if you don't that's why fragility
exactly that's literally what that book
is based on so you end up with Van Jones
writing the only explanation as to why
five black men
another black man was because of white
supremacy when it's just like maybe it's
because they're cops maybe it's because
they have a short fuse because of the
things they witness all day every day
and they were angry and it's nothing to
do with the race of these men because
they were all black I'm sick of
everything having to be someone's race
like look I'll put it this way sometimes
it is race sometimes it is a white cop
hating a black person sometimes it's a
black cop hating an Asian person who
knows I'm just saying it annoys me that
woke people especially but you know
others as well immediately assume the
cause of and the correlation is well it
was the race and I'm like dude come on
man yeah for all we know this guy was
banging dude's wife well Jamil Hill said
the silent part out loud this is what
she said what you were saying about the
police I need I need so many people to
understand this regarding uh Tyree
Nichols several of the police officers
who murdered Freddie gray were black the
entire system of policing is based on
white supremacist violence
like it's it's trying to they're she's
saying get rid of the police I'm just
I'm just it's amazing it's someone
walking up to you and saying listen the
sky is is pink and you go I'm looking up
and the sky is blue actually that's
because you've got a a lens Distortion
perspective and that proves actually
this guy is pink no I can see it dude
when you when when you come out and you
say did you know that the cops who
killed Freddie gray some of them were
also black I'm like so that basically
disproves your whole narrative no it
actually proves it
they can't lose
I I'd love to uh I wish I had that kind
of societal power to say something that
proves the opposite proves the opposite
just be at a casino and it's like
you know I was like hit me 25. actually
they changed the rules Jacks are now
four oh you have 21. I keep winning it
reminds me wasn't there a movie where a
guy was like the only one in the world
who knew how to lie yeah yeah I like
that movie a lot I've never seen it
what's that one it's called The
Invention of Lying yeah so he's he's
broke so it's a world where no one can
lie and then he's broke he can't pay his
rent he's gonna get evicted and then he
goes to the bank and then it like show
like he's like I need to withdraw money
and they're like I'm sorry you don't
have you you only have a certain amount
of money in your bank account then it
zooms into his brain and it shows like a
noron fire and then he goes no I have
800 on my account and she goes that's
strange it doesn't say that must be a
mistake okay I'll withdraw that money
for you because there's no lying so it's
like and then she gives him the money
and he's like whoa and then he basically
becomes like king of the world because
he can move he's funny he's funny I
think it's a great movie he's hilarious
it's like it's like a movie that makes
you think kind of but it is funny movies
in this universe are people sitting in
chairs reading history yeah there's no
fiction so then he starts writing
fiction and people are like watching
these movies all excited thinking it's
real it's kind of like uh like
historically like through the eons that
the the lying deceitful one monkey or
whoever in the in the culture of our
great ancestors were like the ones that
were able to weasel their way into Power
by by hiding the food so that the other
ones couldn't find their food and
they're like where's our food then they
starve and he's like hahaha and so it's
inner genetics that you need to deceive
to get into power but what we want is an
honest leader but you need a strong
Society to support an honest leader or
the leader will just be taken advantage
of and destroyed by evil and subterfuge
it's so easy to burn down what's what's
functional but it's so challenging to
create it to build up yeah so I think
we're on a path to create an honest
leader right now it seems like think
about building a machine and all of the
fine parts that go in it and then
someone can just take a piece of bubble
gum and start right in the whole machine
breaks and then you're like I can't get
that bubble gum out something that's so
stupid and easy to make some bubble gum
some tree sap some rubber destroys you
know 50 years of your work think about
how you could gum up a car think about
how you could pour sugar or some other
garbage into the tank it's like so easy
to tear a machine down it's so hard to
build it and it's easy to lie about
machines when they're not functioning
because like it can cause Panic if
you're honest about the the mishaps and
the dangers of society people can free
if you don't understand the danger but
you're honest about it that's scary like
hey there's a problem I don't have a
solution for and that can cause Panic
which can cause the dissolution of the
system so you're better off historically
lying about it and being everything's
fine close your eyes everything's fine
and if it burns it burns you know
there's no one there to come after me
for lying but but I I think now you know
well one we have the the tools like the
internet where we can solve these
problems climate change you know we can
withdraw the carbon turn it into
graphene we can regrow the plankton in
the ocean by with iron fertilization we
can regrow the coral reefs with uh
cultural micro fragmentation of coral
where you're breaking into a bunch of
pieces and it all grows at once together
you can we can build space elevators and
Elevate you know we can colonize there
are solutions but it's a matter of
organizing them and communicating them
calmly and I think if if we can do that
we won't need to lie to each other well
and everyone has to agree that like
those things are worth doing right like
if you have a small group of people and
they collectively have the same values
and they're like yep we pick him to be
the leader and he's our best interest
you know it's easier but when you talk
about large-scale issues that everyone
has a different role in right like this
comes up with uh you know global warming
all the time will this company this
country is really trying hard to reduce
all of its emissions but this country
doesn't care about it they don't
prioritize it and they are actually
emitting more carbon into the atmosphere
like at what point do we get people to
work on that because they actually have
their own self-interest for their own
communities I just want to go back to
this van Jones thing real quick and just
say just dupe to pause real quick and
just entertain this thought
we we had someone in the chat say I
heard that Tyree Nichols was banging
some dude's wife and we're like whoa I
mean you know we're wondering if there
was something personal here but we can't
verify that CNN's running a story being
like Oh actually the cops were white
supremacists it's like the first one's
more believable this is the point right
we're the mainstream media so it's like
if you came to me and said here's a
video of a man wailing on the face of
another man I'd be like damn what do you
do bang the guy's wife because it is a
simple solution to assume they had a
beef but then imagine a news anchor says
actually we think the real reason is
that that black man swinging his fists
is actually a white supremacist so it's
like okay so you want me to believe
CNN van Jones that those five black men
were anti-black racists with
internalized white supremacy as a more
plausible reason as opposed to homeboy
bang dude's wife yes Dave Chappelle did
the skip Clayton Bixby but he couldn't
even pull it off he had to make the guy
blind you can't just he couldn't be like
you saw his own skin color you know then
the joke it wouldn't even be funny you
know you to believe that like racism and
internal race it's like it's more deadly
than covet you know it's like literally
the most dangerous thing out there that
infects your mind and it can take a
black person and make them actually hate
black people and do something that this
is what they're saying with a straight
face which is amazing but I will say
racism is is disgusting when you talk to
someone that actually is really racist
and they say it and you're like what
what are you it's gross but the thing is
Van Jones is softening it and making it
so you don't he's racist well and I'd
say one further like he wrote this for
CNN it has the opinion label on it right
but then someone else at CNN is going to
say here are some factual reporting and
some people believe it was actually
motivated by white supremacy and they'll
link to his article but then it'll
continue to be cycled and cycled and
cycled until it becomes part of the
normal narratives it's these cops who
were motivated by white paternity beat
this guy like it's it's a kind of nasty
cycle of absorbing these these guesses
at what's going on I agree it's gross
for me I would phrase it as racism is
annoying
on at an academic level and it's gross
on a personal level like we've we have a
bunch of friends of the show who are a
variety of different races and just
thinking about the fact that like a
racist person would say something
negative about any of the guests we've
had on who are not white I mean these
are good people you know these are
people of good opinion we have people
like uh the hoteps come on we have
people like Andy no I know you mentioned
earlier on but we have people about
different backgrounds and I'm like these
are all people who are good people that
that do good work that agree with a lot
of your opinions and then you'd have
someone who just says because the way
they look I have a negative view I'm
like Ah that's the stupidest thing but
but the reason it's annoying to me is
that when you look at a situation like
this with Tyree Nichols we're asking
ourselves what is the context and
Circumstance that results in a con in a
conflict like this it is not because the
men internalized white supremacy that
makes literally no sense it's a strange
crackpot conspiracy theory but it's
annoying to me because I'm like yo I'm
trying to solve a problem here and it's
like you're coming out it's it's like
watching someone with a Chinese finger
trap pull as hard as they can and you're
like my guy just stop okay it's not the
surface level Solution on this one
sometimes maybe you could probably pull
so hard you'll rip the thing apart
but we're trying to figure out why this
happened and I don't think it's because
Tyree Nichols was banging into his wife
but that certainly makes more sense it
could simply be because the cops are
frustrated and angry maybe something
happened earlier in the day maybe Tyree
was they said it was reckless driving
some people are disputing that we have
no idea but when van Jones comes out and
says oh it's because they were racist
it's like bro we're not going to solve
the problem of what's happening with bad
cops like this I'm not saying all cops
when there are bad cops if you just say
racism it's like okay actually that cop
was doing illegal deals in bribery you
know if we're going to actually hold it
hold them accountable we need to hold
them accountable for the things that are
leading to this not just ah racism it's
the racism industrial complex if racism
disappeared tomorrow think of how many
people would be unemployed our economy
every Democrat every non-profit would
just go kaput there would be no need for
half of them uh how many politicians
would lose their jobs like I'm on
Twitter today and I'm seeing like when I
see Kamala Harris and uh and Joe Biden
talking about this guy I don't know it
just really angered me about the
situation Duxbury Mass where they will
never mention those three innocent
children who they will never mention
them but they will make make it seem
like this guy this is the biggest deal
in the world because racism is the
biggest problem confronting our country
why would they want a cure for it when
they can just keep selling the antidote
and keep getting elected let's let's
jump to the next story here otherwise
we're going to go and I think I'm
starting to go in circles we have this
from timcast.com breaking the pat Pelosi
body camera footage released and oh boy
do I have a lot of questions that need
to be answered because you know we were
hearing a lot about what happened with
Paul Pelosi's attack we had a lot of
questions about what seemed to not make
sense
the video seems to clarify a lot of what
we didn't know but oh boy does it raise
a whole lot of questions about what was
going on and uh look I don't know what
happened all I know is it's a very very
weird very weird video now I do want to
say
earlier today I did a segment where I
talked about how I thought it was more
likely it was a drug deal gone wrong
it makes more sense but then they did
release the footage showing to perhaps
smashing the back back door window yeah
and now I'm like okay I'm gonna walk
that back still think it's possible but
probably very unlikely because it would
require them staging a broken window for
some reason which I don't know maybe
they did but I really find it unlikely
I'll just tell you this in the video
footage you can see this right here I
got questions
how is it that
Paul Pelosi in his underwear is holding
a drink of some sort
and the hammer into Pap's hand
and they're both at the door with the
police and and Paul Pelosi does not walk
out to the police he just stands there
looking in a stupor you look at his face
and he's like huh he could run to them
right there they're right there why
doesn't he just run to that because the
Pap's got the hammer and and Paul is
trying to stop is hold it because when
they say hey drop the hammer to Pap
responds you let go of that handle he's
the cops pulling on the hammer you let
go he falls back run just run to the
cops you they're right there but I did I
think they're hammered I think I think
Pablo sees is drunk out of his mind
which is part of why they didn't want to
release it because he's in his boxers
drunk and one in the morning with his
drug dealer whoever this guy is I mean
he's in his own home to be fair to Paul
it's his home if he wants to be drunk in
his boxers
I don't blame him for being a raging
alcoholic 82 years old brother
it's the stock trading that really
bothers me that his wife gives him
inside deals allegedly hold on hold on
we did not excuse that we excused the
drinking right right so go and drink it
go on with your bad self Paul but uh lay
off the stock trades I think I think the
reason he doesn't run to the cops he's
plastered he's just drunk out of his
mind trying to stay calm that's why so
he just gets drunk every night and this
happens
yeah so here's what I here's what I
think I could kill someone in that DUI
too no he injured someone he hit another
car oh really yeah yeah he didn't just
like get a DUI and go on like he hit
another car I can't remember if the if
it was fatal or not he's a drunk I think
the guy breaks in Paul probably already
had a drink was probably just blasted
out of his mind to perhaps like where's
Nancy and he's like
wow you know just like and then he calls
9-1-1 you got to listen to this 9-1-1
call I haven't heard it it does not make
sense yeah it doesn't
people have said
he's trying to de-escalate a crazy man
breaks into your house you don't want to
get into a fight with him you want to
talk him down try and get the police
there there's that old story where the
woman is being abused by her boyfriend
so she calls 9-1-1 and pretends like
she's ordering her pizza and she's like
I'll have a large pepperoni and the
dispatcher's like man this is 9-1-1 and
she goes yes yes
ma'am you can't order pizza here and
she's like yes a large pepperoni ma'am
are you saying this because someone is
around you who will hurt you yeah and
they go okay what's your address and
then they give the address and make it
seem like it's a pizza but Paul Pelosi
wasn't doing that he's like I think I
called you by mistake and then she's
like do you need emergency emergency
services he goes no
uh what do you think and then to Pat
goes I think it's good and she goes and
he goes okay so what happens on the tape
yeah yeah sitting with him and he's or
standing with I thought he was in the
bathroom I thought he was like a bath
nope originally and he's like he's like
she's like do you need emergency fire or
medical and he goes I don't think so I
don't think so
um what do you think and then the pap
goes I think we're good and he goes he
says he thinks we're good but
um but he's not leaving and I'm just
like oh hold on a minute okay so that's
kind of like a hostage call isn't there
a moment where Paul is like why would
the pat be like it is totally fine
you've called the police and I'm
standing here talking with you and I'm
your friend the pap even says I'm a
friend
yeah but Paul has to ask him his name
she's like what's the guy's name and
sure we hear David Dupaco David I mean
like I don't know that they actually
know he's not saying he did I'm just
saying this sure they didn't know maybe
the guy's not his dealer I had that
narrative going on yeah maybe he's just
some Miranda no no for sure for sure but
my question is then why would depap let
Pelosi call 9-1-1
communicate with the dispatcher and
Pelosi maybe he said he was calling
Nancy
she says he doesn't call anyone he calls
the San Francisco PD
should be feeding
oh wait three yeah
it says San Francisco police do you need
help
oh what are the gentleman uh here just
waiting for my wife to come back
zero okay do you need to please fire a
medical for anything eight seconds uh I
I don't think so I don't think so
zero two twenty three and probably eight
seconds yeah there's the uh
um
is the capital police around 220.
my wife they usually hear it they're
usually here at the house protecting my
wife uh no this is San Francisco police
Friday October I I no I understand
um
okay well
and what do you think 15 seconds
uh
it means everything's good I I've got a
problem but he thinks everything's good
okay hold on real quick I've got a
okay maybe it's fair to say he is trying
to de-escalate and he's scared to say
please send police but he literally
asked for the Capitol Police that
doesn't make sense saying that they're
they're usually protecting his wife
maybe he wanted to make the Papi feel
more at ease to know the there's no cops
around but he could have been like oh I
can call them and tell them to bring
Nancy I'll call him right now
well how did how did the pap let him
call 9-1-1 he denies wanting emergency
medical but then literally I'm sorry
Emergency Services police or fire but
then asks if the capital police are
around I think that it sounds like he
was making a phone call to I bet he just
tried to appease him and said uh oh
we'll get Nancy oh you want Nancy I'll
get Nancy on the phone right now and he
makes a call and he's talking about
technology by mistake yeah because you
would if you were to Papi you would not
know he was talking to 9-1-1 there it
makes me think he called the Capitol
Police or his whoever it secures his
house normally first and didn't get a
hold of them because he then is like I
must have called you by mistake because
I'm actually looking for someone else
our Capital police around like he
doesn't actually want to be talking to
San Francisco police he wants to be
talking to cattle police if they think
he actually caught by mistake don't you
have a contact for them I think I think
he I think Paul was drunk out of his
mind and called them by mistake I don't
know for sure but think about this if
the pap was gonna let him make a phone
call why wouldn't he call his wife or
the Capitol Police maybe that's what he
said he was doing we don't know what
he's no no hold on de pep let him call
the police but did the pap know he was
talking to police he's literally talking
to someone who says do you want police
but is he on speakerphone
not on speakerphone why didn't he say
yes send the police I probably because
he the pap was standing there with a
hammer like three feet away okay okay
we gotta pause real quick I'm pulling up
he's on the phone and they say do you
need police fire medical no I don't
think so because the power can at him
can so then why did he say are the
capital police around yeah that's
interesting well you're not going to
make the guy feel more at ease he called
the Capitol Police because he's waiting
drunk lies messing with the pep drunk
logic is no logic yes yes yes maybe no
logic look I'm sorry
let him make a phone call or he made a
phone call and de Pat was getting angry
but if he's concerned if he was doing
the secret thing where he's like please
send me a pizza when the when if the pep
can't hear and she says you need police
he could have he could have been like oh
yeah yeah that'd be that'd be great but
maybe can hear but then he literally
says there's a capital police around to
perhaps certainly heard that yeah and if
if he was concerned if if he was
concerned about perhaps reaction
why did he call sfpd
ask for the capital place instead and
say he doesn't want sfpd when he could
have taken his phone and called drunk
logic is no logic he was I think it's
possible because this doesn't make sense
he was so drunk he accidentally called
sfpd because he's got sfpd and capital
placed in his phone and he's like he
hits the wrong button look there's a
million reasons he could have done this
but when I heard this
everyone's saying it's de-escalation he
doesn't want to Pat to get angry well
the pep standing next to him when he
asks for the capital police maybe but I
hear a knock on the door did you hear
the knock if you pull it back right
before he mentions to Capitol Police
here
protect my wife oh no this is San
Francisco police Friday I I know I
understand
um
no it's before this
uh
he thinks everything's good I I've got a
problem but you can hear the terror in
his voice
so I go back it's earlier
uh he's just uh waiting for her to come
back because he's not going to be here
for a day so I guess I can wait
zero okay do you need to please fire a
medical for anything eight seconds uh I
I don't think so I don't think so
yeah why would he just say yes right
there 23. why would he say I don't think
so yeah but then say are the capital
police around he might have closed
walked into a bathroom and closed the
door when he right before he mentions
what was that
but it could be I
think zero two twenty three and three
eight seconds yeah there's the uh
um I don't think someone's knocking I
think someone's putting something down
on a dresser maybe maybe this is like
right before he opens the doors like can
you please
because of this call they sent police
out later on yeah but I mean when he
says the are the Capitol Police around
and then he opens the door to let David
in something like that like maybe David
didn't hear him say that part
if David wasn't in the room with him and
he was on the phone with police he would
have said send the police and now I need
help
so if David is in the room with him the
argument is that he didn't want to
agitate to pep but then he literally
says are the capital police around so
I'm wondering if he he was like David I
gotta go to the bathroom hold on and
we'll figure this out he goes in the
bathroom close the door makes the call
halfway through right before he you hear
a knock on the door and he's like are
the Capitol Police around because that's
the knock and then he opens the door I
wouldn't he closed the door and say okay
yes please come yeah why would he just
lock the door doesn't make sense
this is what's frustrated me why
everyone is trying so hard to justify
Paul Pelosi is innocent and was actually
a victim when the call doesn't make
sense I'm justifying it because the pap
smashed his window to get into his house
and hit him in the head with a hammer
yeah and also like what are you saying
Paul Pelosi is drunk out of his mind and
doesn't make sense so it's like why why
why try and twist yourself into a
position to justify that Paul Pelosi's
call makes no sense
I mean a lot of people at first were
saying uh the lover thing right that was
that's silly that was silly because if I
mean if he was looking for a gay lover
he he's rich and he's 80 you know he's
in San Francisco he wouldn't find a 300
pound fat loser like that he could find
like a 40 year old maybe he likes him
big
[Music]
the way he said he's here looking for my
wife like he says it all diplomats
definitely looking for Nancy yeah that's
what he said so he's trying to give
David some hope like hey maybe let's
let's let's play through the call
they're usually here at the house
protecting my wife
um no this is San Francisco police
I I no I understand
um
uh
he thinks everything's good I I've got a
problem but he thinks everything's good
okay
think about that call us back if you
need some help or whatever she said
change your mind or if you change your
mind no no this this filament just uh
came into the house uh and he wants to
wait there for my wife to come home and
so uh
do you know who the person is
no I don't know who he is he he uh uh he
has this please
not to uh he told me not to do anything
what is your address okay this is just
weird like that sounds like a lie he
probably knows who he is it sounds like
a lie because he's like he's not gonna
have to do anything the dude's standing
next to him he's literally asking to Pap
what he thinks but then telling the
police depap says don't do anything
doesn't make sense it does what doesn't
make sense is we can say polosi's drunk
but the pap is standing next to him
being like don't you call the police
oh tell them my name's David what yeah I
think the map expected that this phone
call was going to result in Nancy coming
over
uh 26 40. that's what I was saying like
that he was humoring him he's making him
thinking
Friday anyway
and uh you see what he said 18 seconds
okay okay who what's the gentleman's
name
he can hear the dispatcher she said
what's his name he immediately responded
David I can't hear what they're saying
yeah he can hear the dispatcher his name
is David
okay and who is David I I don't know
what's that I'm a friend of theirs
yeah he says he's a friend but
you don't know who he is
right there you're sending squad cars
okay yeah immediately like this is an
emergency
dispatcher yeah that's all so he didn't
know David that's all the dispatch you
need to hear like you don't know who he
is like
I mean look I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend that everybody is smart enough
to break this down but
if I was a 911 dispatcher 911 dispatcher
and a guy called and said yes some guy
just came into my house and uh he's he's
uh wait here for my wife I'd be like
what's your address instantly what's
your address and then I'd call and be
like we got a report of someone entering
someone's house you guys want to go
check it out I'll keep him on the phone
and try and figure out what's going on
but this lady
this 911 dispatcher is just like well
okay I guess like are you kidding you
get these problems back if you need them
yeah do you guys ever hear that dispatch
call where the guy got stabbed and he
called 9-1-1 he's like I've been stabbed
I'm bleeding out and she's like calm
where are you and yeah we are really
where are you at he's like I don't know
or something she's like is that good
confrontation with him there was one
where two kids got shot in a drive-by
and then two young guys young adults
made like 20 years old and they call and
they're like help oh I've been shot and
she goes calm down where he's like I'm
dying I'm I'm here I'm here's the
address and she goes if you keep talking
to me like that that's what it was yeah
that's what I'm thinking about like a
lot of these 911 dispatchers like RMV
employees they're the grumpiest people
like dude I'm in crisis aren't you used
to this like every person a college is
in crisis have you never dealt with a
crazy person before you're like I'm
sorry I don't talk to people unless you
talk to me in a calm voice you're 9-1-1
probably like compassion fatigue you
know they do this all the time it could
be them like being at the point where
like they've just done it all day they
don't know if there could be people that
come into the same day that were
pranking them the whole time you never
know you know what I mean what you're
saying there are a ton of people who
call in insanely hysterical over
something that like if you're the 911
dispatcher starts to feel small in
comparison like the next person calls it
with the murder person for that calls
you because someone bumped their car
look at the Veritas video from yesterday
the guy called the cops for that for
asking them questions the cops are like
sorry to interruptly no sir
um I I think the word thing to me is
that like she's like well so calls back
and Paul's like no I have a problem I
don't want him to be here like I can't
explain the beginning of the call it is
weird no matter how you look at it I
personally tend to lean towards like
yeah I think it does seem like he's
trying to like alert someone and I still
have the Instinct that he maybe tried to
get a hold of capital police first and
it didn't I I just gotta I gotta I gotta
stop real quick
take everything into consideration with
the 9-1-1 call and then take into
consideration that he answers the door
with the police holding a beverage yeah
maybe it's water that he won't put down
that he won't put down and when the pap
twists the hammer out of his hand
he still won't drop his drink to try and
stop the hammer alcoholism good drink
maybe that's some Alpha thing he's like
trying to establish like yo I'm in
control here I don't know six thousand
dollar whiskey he's like it's not like
it's not I'm not dropping he's not
buying the cheap stuff no wow I mean
Nancy's got that 20 ice cream or
whatever you know in her fridge remember
that maybe Paul felt like the cops are
gonna get this guy off of me so let's
just move on some people in a crisis
situation are good at staying calm and
trying to talk The person down stuff
like that but like I I don't know that
Paul Pelosi is maybe he is but to then
walk around with your your like night
cap is very strange I'm gonna play this
there's only a few more seconds
here we go let's play the rest okay he's
telling me I'm being very leading so I I
gotta stuff on you okay
you sure I can stay on the phone with
you just to make sure everything's okay
off the phone
zero two twenty okay okay and zero eight
thank you okay bye
um I don't understand here I don't
understand why considering we heard all
of that he didn't say to David
if you want me to call Nancy I can I can
call the the the the the the the people
who who drive around take care of it the
police are saying I'll call him and let
him know and tell him to bring her over
he would have believed that probably I
mean he literally said on the phone I
want Capital police
I don't understand why he said is the
are the Capitol Police there instead of
just saying
are like you're the police will do yeah
right any police will do he's probably
panicking as he was drunk and and not
used to this kind of thing because it
just didn't a lot of it was just kind of
desperate like Capitol Police when he's
on the San Francisco 9-1-1 call and he
asked for Capital police that's a that's
a weird desperation that's why I want to
know like why is he like I need Capital
police like if you're drunk and you're
in an emergency even if you're managing
to stay weirdly calm like as soon as you
get any kind of police wouldn't you be
like yes yes like to me it's it's
interesting that he is specifically like
I I don't know that I want to talk to
you but I definitely want to talk to
Capital it's also possible that Capitol
Police has a contingent in San Francisco
watching the Pelosi's house that are in
touch with the police department but 911
dispatcher didn't know that uh Philip R
super chatted that he was trying to
speak in code telling her that he was
Pelosi's husband I do agree with that he
says you know he's waiting for my wife
Nancy Pelosi and it's just like the
funny thing about that is like my guy
nobody knows who that is go nobody knows
that is I I will I will I will we should
make it Pelosi is nobody knows who Nancy
Pelosi is I think there are tons of
people who couldn't name this people
what I'd be willing to bet you're in the
news yeah go to times go to Times Square
and I will give you 10 bucks for every
person who says they know Nancy Pelosi
is yeah what percentage of the country
do you think knows who Nancy Pelosi is
12 adults adults oh yeah 12 12 that's it
yep what yeah I was thinking that today
one of the most identifiables have you
ever watched fleka's videos I have where
he goes on the street and asks them
basic questions like what name a country
that starts with the letter U and they
go uh I don't know it's like United
States of America oh come on do you
think uh you think I was thinking last
night oh what's it no go ahead oh we're
in an echo how I'm in an echo chamber
even though I'm trying to be open mind I
call I texted my buddy out in L.A and I
was like what do people in your Zone
think about Ukraine do they want an
escalation because I'm in kind of like a
Libertarian conservative Echo chamber
and everybody wants out of there they
want the US not involved and so he
messaged back he's like we want peace we
want Russia to not be invading and it's
like man I just I still have like
portals to people in other Echo Chambers
but we are and even social media is
intensifying that yeah I was to say my
uncle tuber is my friends who are not at
all interested in politics but could
tell you everyone who's competing on The
Bachelorette and I like them dearly but
they just have lives and jobs and they
don't follow the news super intensely
they're all smart and wonderful they
probably don't know who the Speaker of
the House how many people do you think
right now know Kevin McCarthy is less
than Nancy Pelosi I think she's more
famous than him maybe maybe only because
she was speaker than not then speaker
and she's been in for a really long time
but I would be willing to bet that if
you went out into Times Square
and spent one eight hour shift it would
not financially harm me to pay you ten
dollars for every individual you
interview that says I know who Nancy
Pelosi is she was the Speaker of the
House in the 117th and 16th Congress
some people I would you know what I
would say I would say half correct
answers like she that Democrat lady I'll
accept that but I'd be willing to bet
after eight hours of asking people I
might end up losing in Times Square I
don't know a couple hundred bucks
all right Mark Dice go do it
full trans I want to see all of it I
would say 45 with no need to below 45
I'm gonna be over under a 45 I'm gonna
be about 12 10 15 12 or 10 she's just
not that interesting no offense Nancy
but I mean it's a politician people
aren't really into that kind of thing
we're in like yeah how about this one
ask ask someone who their current
Congressional right oh that they would
not know that they would not know like
nobody knows like Mike unless you're
congresswoman's AOC or somebody like
famous like that you're not gonna know
that most people aren't gonna know who
they are I agree how many followers does
Pelosi have on Twitter is an interesting
question that is a good question Twitter
also is a tough one because it is like a
political social network right
it's very important people on Twitter
probably you probably how many people
8.1 million followers but how many
followers on Instagram does she have
right I feel like there are more people
who are on that platform she doesn't run
her account like she's way too old
that's not what that's what that's not
why I ask though I don't care about she
runs the account or not it's do reg 1.5
million on Instagram decent how many
significant drop off right like right
how many Twitter Twitter is the news in
politics space Instagram is casual
celebrity yeah 1.5 million followers I'm
sorry bro that's nothing yeah it's not
that bad that's that's I mean it's less
than AOC who remember after she got
elected very famously did her skincare
routine on the train down from New York
to DC like she is working the crowd that
she thinks will elect her aoc's got 8.6
million Instagram followers but 14
million Twitter I think
AOC on Twitter yeah I think she's like
14 million on Twitter you want someone
to look it up let's do uh yeah
I think she's the top congresswoman for
Casey neistat has three million
followers
exactly yeah
I love that you think he is who's Casey
Knight said Casey neistat is the they
call him the Godfather of logging he's
like the liberal version of Michael
malice no they might sound alike yeah
vlogging a vlog a vlogging okay Casey
Vlogs before Casey neistat where like
people with their phones filming
themselves and then he brought cinematic
editing and uh production to YouTube
vlogging gain 10 million subscribers
he's got 3 million followers on
Instagram he's on magazine covers and
you don't know who he is
my bad dude you're okay you're a
Politico I'm gonna follow you and you
you think everybody's got to know Nancy
Pelosi is but she's got less than half
the followers of Casey neistat and he's
a mainstream celebrity you've never
heard of for the record Alexandria
Cortez has 13.4 million on Twitter is
that her professional account or is that
her person it just is at AOC so I guess
that's personal okay yeah that was the
one that existed before she was a
congresswoman that what do you guys
think about a congressman having their
own and a congressional one what I don't
like about at POTUS for instance is the
president of the United States uh is
that it gets handed off to the next guy
yeah what about the DM so no private DMS
on there um
as best they can yeah and we get
scrubbed I guess it makes sense yeah I
think I in like imagine Bill Clinton had
one he's texting Monica on the DMS then
he's got to hand it over to the next guy
bush is like what's happening here where
no I I mean I think I like the intent
right like to be like this is my
personal opinion versus like how I am
representing my constituents online but
I think it's especially it's really easy
to conflate the two uh and if you say
like oh but I said that on my personal
account are you supposed to be held less
accountable to it you know what I mean
you know who Billy eilish is I do right
a 108 million followers so it's like an
entirely different league but that's a
like girl like she looks like a little
boy and she's got a high voice right
she's definitely not sex I like green
hair well it depends on who he asks
she's young yes she's like 20. she's
wicked woke yeah she performed at the
Democratic National Convention but does
it mean she's woke or is she just like
default like insanely woke like well no
purple hair like one of those people no
not necessarily just because of the way
from dresses doesn't mean she's super
well she also has like reviews against
pornography Etc she's like staunchly
anti-pornography so she's a Matt Walsh
fan but I was you know she's definitely
a Democrat I was trying to I'm guessing
the reason I bring her up is just
because I'm like who's the most famous
like younger person I can think of and
you know who that was you know so I'm
just I'm I don't know I don't think that
many people would know who Nancy Pelosi
is let's actually I'll do I'll set up a
poll we'll set up a polls are all gonna
know who she is but right yeah well I
mean it makes a difference and we're
measuring off of uh Twitter and
Instagram like we said Twitter is much
more political that's more news oriented
Instagram's more lifestyle there are a
lot of people who like it we're not
talking about Facebook because I don't
think anyone is super involved in
Facebook anymore and let's remember that
gen Z is actually going to measure you
based on how many uh follows you have on
Tick Tock right which I'm confident
Nancy Pelosi is if she's on Tick Tock
she's she's far behind any of the tick
tock celebrities
do you have a tick tock accounted
have it I don't want to use it I just
don't want to give in because it's
literally owned by it's Chinese spyware
yeah and I'm just telling myself no no
no but when you're in my line of work
and you're doing you know blogs and
you're talking about pop culture and
stuff it's like everything is on Tick
Tock it's literally impossible to avoid
it sucks do you know what the third
amendment is
yeah I taught history I should know this
ah no I forgot that dude in the in
January 6 will put his feet on Pelosi's
desk he was asked by the prosecutor
First Amendment you know it's where the
British can't sleep in your house
correct
the government can't order soldiers in
your home and it actually came up during
covid but they asked that dude to put
his feet on Pelosi's desk they're like
you know do you like the first amendment
yes what is it you're like Second
Amendment do you know what the third
amendment is and he says no recently
there was a a judge being nominated this
one was really funny and uh the judge
was asked I can't remember who asked it
do you know what article 5 of The
Constitution is I saw that and she said
it doesn't come to mind and he goes okay
how about article two it just doesn't
come to mind article two a judge not
knowing is insane Article Five it's like
the Amendments one uh five is the
Amendments right uh the convention of
States okay article two is the executive
branch so and she was like I have no
idea it's like come on dude wow but you
know I know that she wasn't gonna get
that question right yes ahead of time
but here here's why I bring that up it's
like when a judge can't tell you about
the executive branch article in the in
the Constitution I don't think the
average person is going to tell you who
Nancy Pelosi is now we had with the poll
the polls got 2 580 votes 75 people do
people know who Nancy Pelosi is 75 say
yes but when you have a political show
right like I sell you should go on any
lifestyle Instagram like whatever
someone who doesn't talk about politics
and ask Their audience the majority of
the country does not vote in the
midterms like less than 50 votes in the
midterms and still foreign
still out of like 2 000 votes you know
it goes to show you that some people
literally don't know who she is well
that doesn't say do you know it just
says do people know and so I changed
that that's true I changed it to do
normies know who Pelosi is and now it's
no yeah so I I wonder if the people in
the chat were thinking it meant them
right yeah do you know Pelosi is they're
all great and informed that's the same
thing we're just talking about
projection earlier when you know things
there's an assumption that other people
know it exactly we are in an echo
chamber dude my I I I was I talked
abandon about the election 2020 and he
was like you know he thinks Trump won
and all that stuff and I was like I A
friend of mine posted a video of him
carrying his mail-in ballot while
filming he's got his phone like this and
he's carrying it he drops in the mailbox
and I'm like this dude couldn't tell you
what Supreme Court Justice meant he
would just like you you'd say what what
does Supreme Court justice mean is that
when like you win a case in the Supreme
Court
you need a new Taco Bell seasoning sauce
I mean not that bad he'd be like does
that mean like you got Justice and like
you won it's like no it means the people
who are the literal judges who determine
these things he couldn't tell you even
the concept of that if you go to if you
go to these people like I I these are
people I know who skateboard these are
people I know play music I can hit up
any one of my friends and ask them about
one of these things and they'll just be
like I got no idea what you're talking
about I will say to them name a sitting
Supreme Court Justice and they'll go a
sitting Justice what does that mean like
like do you make sure you see like do
you mean like do you mean like a current
case or something no no like the
justices right like the people who said
on the Supreme Court oh oh yeah I have
no idea and I'm not talking about stupid
people I'm talking about a guy who could
tell you how to rebuild a car he can
break the whole thing down for you put
together and be like I I don't I don't
pay attention to that stuff
so I it's just me that's just me right
now I said do normies know who Pelosi is
63 said no
maybe I don't know and that's fine I
have no problem with ignorant people who
don't follow politics we just should not
be encouraging them to vote and that's
the problem is Democrats are encouraging
the dumbest people to vote because their
strength in numbers and so they're like
well you know nothing about politics but
trust me just look for this person and
we're gonna here's a bunch of ballots
for you and have them by here by this
date uh in the Box just drop it in there
and things will get better if you do
that I I gotta read this Super Chat that
came in from Paul a he says Tim you keep
asking who opened the door at Pelosi's
house why do you think they had an
exorcism math checks out there you go I
told you I thought it was haunted you
know she had an exorcism right yeah
at the house
they brought in these guys are crazy
hippies I didn't know what did that what
are there in San Francisco I don't know
they brought in priests Catholics right
they probably thought like dark energy
soul out or something I don't even know
what happens it's like you cast demons
out of whatever it's in and she thinks I
saw someone who was like they did that
did the The Souls of all the dead baby
she's allowed to be murdered come out of
her walls or something like that because
like she's Catholic but then she's for
abortion I mean I I I respect that she's
like I I want to get rid of whatever bad
vibes are in my house because my husband
got attacked but I don't know she did
that afterwards yeah I don't know if the
Poltergeist is the one who opened the
door she really did that yeah yeah it
was the first I heard I've seen it in
your I mean New York Post reporters does
she talk about it did she like tell the
world I should have video recorded it
and made a documentary on it that was
awesome we should we should totally make
like a Paranormal Activity Style movie
about the Pelosi's house being haunted
and like you know
how it all went down the ghost of Sam
Hyde okay
it's like
it's more of an indictment on San
Francisco that there are so many people
out there like this that can just walk
like I assume they live in the rich part
of town but he his fat ass ended up over
there and got inside the house and it's
just like that to me is the bigger part
of the stories like San Francisco has
turned into a hello where fat lardos
like the papiers walking around I I
think I think we could totally write an
awesome horror movie script that
propagandize everything that happened
like depap is at the house and they're
having drinks together and then you know
he's like I'm gonna go out for a smoke
it was in the backyard and then the door
slams and the ghost appears in the
window going he's like no and he takes
the hammer and smashes through the
window trying to get back in I gotta
save Paul he's trying to get back in
there there that goes into it he's
swinging the hammer at the ghost but the
ghost is like just moving around and
then also they hear a knock at the door
and then Paul looks and they're like now
what and they open it and then the ghost
goes into the pap and then he's like
what's happening no he doesn't throw his
butt and that's why the copper the cop
reached into the yeah in the video you
can see the cop reach into perhaps
yeah I saw it was the crack it was weird
it was a lot it's very you know like you
said it was a crazy place that's why
they said the video was graphic
like Pelosi's like dying you're like
yeah oh can we so we can't show that
part it's pretty brutal but it really is
telling that Paul was not the villain in
this one I think when David I mean David
just turns and smashes him in the head
and then you hear people don't actually
see it you don't
he's convulsing yeah and like for sure
if it's an act I mean that's I'm just
saying you said you you see him you see
him make make a swing but right but it's
off shot yeah they right they leave the
frame and that's when the connection is
made but then they run around the corner
you see blood on the ground you hear
Paul gasping yeah I think she's pointing
out that David's lawyers were against
this video coming out because they said
it would be incriminating to him uh and
also he's entered a not guilty plea but
not Not Guilty by reason of mental
insanity or defect right so like I
wonder if they'll change that now that
this is out they'll be like oh well he
was having a mental break and that was
what's going on what time Carlo Magno
says Tim we Catholics do not claim
Pelosi bring back the potato man we need
his voice oh I never said you claimed
her I just meant that she claims you
guys yeah bring back the Potato Man
MD no he's not really a doctor yeah
there were some others there were some
other news we're going to talk about
what's going on I'm chilling we're
having a good time this Pelosi thinks
great I feel like this is a resolution
to something that's kind of was a big
deal then kind of went to the back of my
brain I'm so glad I saw that video
because I it makes things make a lot
more sense that some crazy wacko smashed
a window and hit a guy in the head
that's a lot easier it's literally how
that guy from NBC described it who I
believe was fired or censored he
described exactly what happened in the
video and then they wanted to hide it I
don't know why they want to hide it
because uh I mean maybe they're
embarrassed because he's in his
underpants yeah and he's drunk debashery
you know what time was it at this happen
one in the morning that's the thing do
we have time frames and all these things
because there's somebody talking about
the time frames well you see the the
reason why they didn't want it released
was because they needed time to Stage it
they're bringing the actors they
actually just shot that yeah we filmed
those the other day it looks just like
them I want to hear about you Aiden for
a minute because we're gonna you told me
earlier you got Turtle Boy news yes so
what how did you get into this whole
industry so I was uh an 11th grade
history teacher at a public school in
Massachusetts and
um I started a Blog using my real name
uh called Aiden from worcester.com and I
got in trouble for it because uh some of
my opinions were were the wrong ones
basically like you're not allowed to
have controversial takes or whatever and
I got suspended for five days with no
pay and I was it's hard to fire a
teacher but I was this close like
they're like one more slip up
um because of my social media postings
and you're out so I'm like if I want to
keep doing this I need to be anonymous
so I created a Blog called turtle boy
there's a funny statue in downtown
Worcester of a boy who looks like he's
having sex with a turtle if you Google
it he's actually riding it it's
completely Innocent but it's like the
first thing people think of when they
think of Worcester so what's called the
blog turtle boy and uh it started being
anonymous I did it while I was teaching
and then we went to a game in Buffalo in
September of 2014 to watch the Patriots
murder the bills again and uh I filmed
Buffalo fans up there because they're
crazy and wild and uh like I was in the
porta potty they tried to shake it
dumping me over it was awesome time and
I came home I put the videos all on my
blog and it kind of went viral in
Buffalo and so all these Buffalo people
want to find out like who's this guy
making fun of us and saying we're
Savages and blah blah blah somebody
found out I got doxed and a buffalo
blogger wrote A Blog about me saying
this is the guy that on our city
and blah blah blah and next thing you
know our school was being inundated with
emails I was getting cc'd on all of them
like you haven't a you know horrible
words basically the school was getting
threats and a police officer from Dudley
had to come up to my classroom like
before the last period of the day and
say we gotta get you out of here and so
they brought me down the principal's
office the union was there and they're
like we we're we just want to make sure
you're okay uh we're gonna give you paid
time off and just go and we'll figure
this out they were gonna try and
basically what they the resolution was
they offered me a full year salary to
walk away and I took it because I'm like
well I want to do I don't want to be a
teacher anymore it was getting to the
point like I got right out before Trump
right out before
um there was no transgender students
when I was there I don't even know like
none of that stuff existed in the 24th
what year 24 2014. and so I'm like in it
and so I started doing this it was right
around the Ferguson stuff too and I'm
like I turned it into a business I just
got a bunch of advertisers I lost them
all to boycotts then I got banned from
Google AdSense I had to create a new
page tvdailynews.com it used to be
called turtleboysports.com
um and like I said I've overcome
countless uh unprecedented I would say
uh censorship and de-platforming I've
been sued more times than I can count
undefeated in court I have multiple
restraining orders on people who are
constantly threatening me and my family
and it's been a struggle at times
there's been many times I've wanted to
quit but uh I I've dedicated my life to
this so this is what I'm doing it
sounded like in 2014 you were like one
of the early maybe not a victim but uh
someone that was affected by like a
cancel culture mob totally did you know
other people that were also going
through that at that time no I didn't
and and the big thing I noticed uh and
what upset me was I'm like so I can't
say these things because I'm a teacher
like that's what they said I had an
opinion I wrote a Blog I don't know if
you guys remember uh the Richie
Incognito story uh player in the Miami
Dolphins he was accused of bullying his
teammate Jonathan Martin and my take on
it was I'm like give me a break 300
pound man getting bullied it's football
you guys run into each other and the
school told me that this blog violates
our anti-bullying policy because a
student could read it and then feel
uncomfortable going to you with bullying
issues and that's when I realized that
there's no such thing as free speech for
public servants I'm like I can't say
this so if I was an accountant I could
say this but because I'm a teacher I
can't say this what about my first
amendment rights the government
employees don't have First Amendment
rights right I learned that the hard way
they really don't have First Amendment
rights but I like the first amendment
and I really like I don't like censoring
myself I hate censoring myself and I'm
like I just took a chance you know it's
the American Spirit of just quitting
your job I mean teaching is a
comfortable position like you're never
gonna be rich but you'll never be poor
you'll have a pension you know when
you're going to retire and and your
whole life is basically written out for
you and you'll get a house keep at the
end of it and you'll move on but I'm
like you know what that's no way to live
I want to take a chance I want to do
something here and here I am sitting
with you fine people so I think it
worked out in the end what were you
teaching taught United States history so
have you been still teaching history
through your blog uh you know I I got to
keep up on a little more I went to
Harpers Ferry I come in out here and
that was really surreal yeah the battery
the old battery where they built the
weapons it's all like down to Rubble
they came in and they burned it to the
ground yeah he needed a better plan that
didn't work out too well uh maybe if he
had Twitter he could have figured
something out but uh yeah I mean I I
love United States history I I often
incorporate it into a lot of blogs that
I write just the perspectives
um on this stuff um and I I I'm one of
those teachers like a lot of people
think that like the public schools are
infected by liberal teachers there are a
lot of liberal teachers but there's also
a lot of really good history teachers my
department the majority of the social
studies Department Shepard Hill voted
for uh Republicans I can say that
without a doubt and uh I I made sure my
number one goal as a teacher was to make
sure my students at the end of the year
had no idea who I voted for and they did
and I think any good teacher that should
be your goal your your students should
have no idea who you voted for you
should present every time I I brought up
a controversial issue that I would teach
about like abortion and I have strong
opinions on it but I'm not going to
vocalize it I'm going to say here is
what the pro-choice side says here is
what the pro-life says these ideas are
in conflict and you get to make your own
decisions based on those things and
unfortunately like you see on Libs of
tick tock a lot of you know a lot of
teachers don't do that and also it
sounds like if you do go on social media
and express yourself then that also just
kind of upends that intention of them
not knowing what your political views
are because you've expressed them on
social media right and that's where you
know you get in trouble you're like you
know my social media was pretty private
and I and I got in trouble one time I
would say like typically teachers and
students are not supposed to be oh I was
never friends with any students or
anything like that but they're like well
this kid a kid could see it because
you're friends with this person and this
person's friends with this person and
then they might see it that way I mean
that's how ridiculous this was like
schools are petrified of uh any sort of
controversy like that when it comes to
one side of the aisle like you can be as
radical as you want as a leftist and
write the most insane uh Pro BLM things
on your on your Facebook page so the
cows come home you're not going to get
in trouble yeah but if you have the
wrong conservative opinions on social
media that's an issue you think if you
were at a private school would have been
different it would have been uh even
worse because there's no unionization at
a private school like the least the I'm
not anti-union at all like the Union uh
protected me with this and as much they
got me a deal like as much as they could
and that's what you pay union dues for
is not is for emergencies it's basically
Insurance like in case something bad
happens I mean there's teachers that
were wrongly accused of touching kids
right and the union was there for them
like the first thing they taught us at
Shepherd Hill was uh if you ever have a
girl for extra help
do it in the hallway never in your room
never have a kid in your room ever I got
there right after um a sex scandal if
you Google her Amber Jennings
hot hot had sex with a 15 year old
student I was asked on my interview I
swear he asked me at this interview he's
like
um so you're a young guy you're 24 uh so
what would you do if a young student
want came on to you and tried to hit on
you it's like well I would tell her no
this is inappropriate like I don't know
what the right answer like do some
people say yeah I would hook up with her
like no that's so crazy they didn't even
ask like yeah I'd call the police yeah
it's such a wonderful question of the
room and like it's I would tell her it's
inappropriate and then probably email
her mom and say this is what happened in
school today you think that's the right
move is to contact the parents oh yeah
you gotta cover your bases man that you
cannot take any chances like with a lot
like a kid goes home and starts saying
Mr Carney hit on me you know something
like that you got to get out of that you
got to be you gotta get ahead of that
because some of these kids are twisted
yeah don't be alone yeah never I'm never
alone with a student in the classroom we
used to have guidance counselor in their
little office you'd go sit down in their
little office with them yeah maybe they
didn't have maybe that cameras it was it
was the 90s at that point though yeah do
that anymore oh wow because now some kid
comes out and says to the counselor uh I
want a free period after you know lunch
or whatever and say well you can't have
that well I'm just going to say that
you've had racist things to me and
they'll go uh
so you're not alone anymore I mean
probably some schools are doing it but
they're in for rude awakening what these
kids are going to be doing do you also
go to the pr uh the uh principal if they
if a kid comes to you and is hitting on
you or something well that never
happened luckily um so but I think you'd
probably tell everyone I would tell
everyone I would I made it I mean I was
24 when I first started there and you
know I'm young and like some of the
seven like the seniors would hint at
inappropriate things like they would ask
the first question they would say things
like
um so do you go out on the weekends and
I'm like I know where this is going
you're like and I'm like if I go yeah
and like I want to make myself seem like
such a square loser that they don't even
act like I'm so lame like no that's
inappropriate like and it stops real
quick they're like this guy's lame and
that's the way I want to come across I
didn't want to be the cool teacher the
cool teachers are shitty teachers quite
frankly they're in it for the wrong
reasons I wanted to be the lame teacher
that taught you history and that's what
I took pride in uh you know there was
three Junior classes in the school and
my students did uh on average 10 to 12
points higher at the test at the end of
the year than and the other kids because
I made sure we got up the present-day
American history a lot of teachers only
made it to like JFK or maybe Vietnam but
I made sure we got through Reagan and
Carter and and even Clinton and uh like
we talked about the Kanye West I
remember showing the Kanye West uh uh
Hurricane Katrina one like we ended with
Katrina you know so we got up to the
present day and I took a lot of pride in
that um because I was there to educate I
wasn't there to be your friend I wasn't
there to hook up with girls and I just
don't understand the teachers that go
into it it's like what is wrong with it
do you think some teachers go into it
looking for validations from a younger
audience I think a lot of the teachers
that you see that have had sexual
affairs with students I think they're
the people that didn't get laid in high
school right that were just like and for
the and like didn't they weren't and now
for the first time
hot girls are interested in them and it
gives like it's exciting for the first
time and they're like oh this is should
I do it maybe she won't tell anyone and
I don't know what they're thinking I
have a feeling there's a lot of budding
teachers in chat people listening that
are preparing to become teachers or want
to become teachers what did you do like
to get a 13 more better value in your
test scores particularly were you able
to gauge what you were doing versus what
other teachers were doing make sure they
learn it a lot of students right when
you assign homework like you probably
had this when you were in school like
okay read this 10 pages answer the
questions at the end okay what do they
do they skim it and they answer it I
didn't I once I realized that they were
just copying out of a book I'm like this
is ineffective this is they're not
learning anything this way what I want
you to do I don't want you to answer any
questions I want you to read it I want
you to understand it then tomorrow when
you come in you're going to get a quiz
every single day 10 question multiple
choice because we haven't gone over it
in class I'm going to give you a two you
get to get two wrong and that's what I'm
going to grade it on and that's all I
wanted kids to do just read understand
and they learned it a lot better that
way I got a feeling if we did audiobooks
in school for kids that don't want to
read obviously we want to teach kids how
to read and become literate so there's a
value to reading but it's so long it
takes so long for me I was like I am not
reading your crap teach but if it was
audio I think that might have been I
learn audibly I think that could help
you have to make it interesting like you
can't just teach like okay there was
this act and then there was this act you
got to get into it a history teacher
especially has to have energy and they
have to really love the topic like if I
was teaching the John Brown rage it's
like okay check this out you know like
so there's a guy John Brown and you have
five sons and these dudes were crazy I
don't know what they were thinking you
know like they they wanted to take this
Arsenal it's memorable didn't all his
kids die like before him yes uh most of
them did and he survived somehow yeah
yeah hanged him his five kids were
fighting with him yeah this is a slave
or this is like an abolitionist
the first person died of Harper's Ferry
was a black man they accidentally shot
John their side John Brown
if you if if someone existed today that
was like John Brown he would be locked
up in two seconds as a violent murderous
cycle like it's literally an
Insurrection he led an Insurrection I
mean he killed a bunch of people and
like him and his crew and it was in
Bleeding Kansas I believe yes he was in
Kansas before yeah yeah so Bladen Kansas
was like we don't want new states to be
slave states
then other people were like they did so
he goes down along with many other
people and they were it was it was it
was the pre-civil war was Bleeding
Kansas it was many Civil War and then
you know what his big mistake was I mean
you probably know all about the John
Brown being outnumbered no no no no he
let the train leave yeah so after he
took over the Harpers Ferry Armory a
train was coming in and he said okay
fine you can leave Tran makes it to
Baltimore sends word hey you know
extremist guy Insurrection treason just
took over the Harpers Ferry Army and
this is um at the time I'm pretty sure
it was still Virginia it wasn't West
Virginia yeah it was that's right then
they then they tell the feds deploy the
troops if he didn't let that train leave
he would have been able to secure the
city and secure the Armory and the other
thing too is he was trying to format to
slave revolt yeah and they never showed
up yeah they're like for he asked
Frederick Douglass to can you do it in
French I was like nah chill look we're
all set I've got I'd like to hear your
guys opinions I've got uh on my Twitter
Banner it's a picture of John Brown you
know that picture where he's got the
Bible and one hand and a rifle on the
other except it's my face photoshopped
on it love it should I take that down
should I change that not a little too
it's the the problem with John Brown is
it's just like man
stopping slavery
it's legit but yo he literally just
killed innocent people like I guess the
question is whether you view them as
innocent but like there are stories of
him walking up to he was also a he
killed one of his the first person who
died was on their side yeah and was
running back towards them one of the
stories is that he walked up to a
landowner a slave owner he believed I'm
saying this specifically because he
walks up to a guy and just shoots him in
the face kills him and so it's like okay
hold on there a minute man you know what
I mean like that that's that's I don't
know about all that it's like when it
when it comes to war even uh Abraham
Lincoln wasn't really trying to end
slavery as much as they tried to create
that myth that he was so
abolitionists a lot of really great
people a lot of really passionate people
who fought in the Civil War because they
knew it was a path to the end but it's
like man people like John Brown that's
tough It's you know people want to look
back and be like he was an abolitionist
it's like yeah he was a murderous
psychopath like I I loved teaching uh
World War II and especially the Civil
Rights Movement we actually uh one of my
favorites was uh the Little Rock Nine
like I loved teaching about that and we
actually set up a situation where we had
pen pals I contacted Little Rock Central
High School
um which is like a prestigious high
school today
um it's actually paid for by the federal
government and my students had pen pals
with theirs because we watched a
documentary about what Little Rock uh
Central High is like 50 years later it's
60 black 40 white extremely segregated
still but self-segregated you know like
black kids congregate towards black kids
white kids congrate towards White um
white kids so I really love doing like
the whole pen pal thing kind of like
brought it to life they're like oh we're
talking to other kids in another state
I've never been to and probably never
will go to I don't know anything about
but this is cool what's the Little Rock
Nine uh the The Little Rock Nine where
uh it was the first school that was
forced to be desegregated in 1957.
um this Brown versus Board of Ed in 54
said you have to desegregate schools and
no southern states were until Little
Rock decided we're going to do this
um and so nine black kids signed up to
go to school a mob met them outside the
Arkansas National Guard did nothing to
stop the mob and so Eisenhower had to
come in and uh basically send the 101st
Airborne literally the D-Day guy's in to
walk the the children had to walk around
school uh getting protected by these
people we got rides in New York oh do we
yeah uh so far the videos I'm seeing are
relatively light they're smashing a cop
car window uh Drive uh windshield sorry
and uh I'm seeing other people post
about riots popping up but so far the
video I've Just Seen because I got a
notification it was like Hey riots are
kicking off and I'm like okay what's
going on and then I see a video and
they're in Times Square jumping on a cop
car Times Square yeah but it's I the
video is not like people throwing bricks
or anything it's jump in a car and
smashing the windshield I wonder how
many people have actually seen the video
yo but I'm watching like even a bunch of
conservatives are like yo they straight
up murdered that guy yeah like cops were
taking turns yeah for holding him and
pounding on him for sure and and and so
it's a murder like murders happen every
day yeah and it's like and the bad
people the people that did it are being
held accountable so what are we doing
here yeah they're uh hawk newsom's in
New York saying FPS f-pace so they're
basically just calling for violence wow
Union Square like like I said it
wouldn't even matter what was on the
video that's what I thought today too
it's like it really doesn't matter
what's on the video they're gonna Riot
no matter this is why I left the city
this is why we went outside of the city
we're not completely in the middle of
nowhere but we're middle of nowhere ish
we get comments from people they're like
coming to Tim Pool's house was crazy
it's like pitch black you got this long
Winding Road that's right we're on top
of a mountain because uh you know New
York's gonna be when when the Summer of
Love happened there was a guy who called
9-1-1 he said help there's a fight break
at my apartment and the the dispatcher
said sir the city is under attack what
would you have us do yeah when was that
2020 wow yeah so uh yeah cities are in a
rough get some chickens get out of
cities but we're gonna jump to Super
Chat so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member of timcast.com
we got a massive library of members only
shows you can watch going all the way
back the years of the show and uh check
it out supports our work and our
cultural Endeavors we really do
appreciate it let's read what you all
have to say in the super chats all right
let's see Emily Kanata says Turtle
writer for life are you going to talk
about that story out of Duxbury oh we
mentioned earlier the three it's
horrible stories
oh right right it's like very few times
do you write a story where it's actually
like horrible like you didn't want to
write it just happened it just happened
a couple days ago and if you look at the
pictures the youngest child just just
died today yeah and if you look at this
woman's Facebook page I mean like the
perfect family like I love you and it's
just it's horrible it's absolutely
horrible this is a really great Super
Chat from minotaure says the Pelosi
video is what you get when you hire the
writers of reno911 to write your psyops
Has It Go on I dig it kinda here we go
total Wildlife Management this is at 801
says Memphis protesters have blocked the
old 55 Memphis Bridge
wow so that was that was an hour and a
half ago that was a while ago we'll see
where we go we'll see who we are man I
assume that crosses the Mississippi must
be a major bridge probably Mr Dyson says
Tim I tried sharing with you on Twitter
that the Memphis police chief was
recruited from Atlanta GA and a
supporter of BLM which might explain the
Friday release of body camera footage
they want it to happen yeah yeah man
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I had to
do The Crying Game shower scene earlier
I was walking on the street some lady
said I was handsome but another slapped
my butt that Omen asked me out in a day
oh the humanity there was this uh meme
going around from this feminist group
it's a comic and it was like how would
men like getting harassed or whatever
and it was a four panel comic where it's
like a guy walking down the street and a
woman's like hey handsome you're looking
pretty good you should smile more and
then he's like thanks then the next one
is like a office where the one's like
hello lovely gentlemen they're smiling
then it was a woman being like wow you
fixed that computer all by yourself
that's impressive and he's like thanks
and it's just like do feminists just not
understand guys at all yeah the crazy
thing to me is that the woman who wrote
that was outright saying that if she
fixed her computer and you went wow did
you fix your computer by yourself it's
impressive that's an offensive thing to
say to somebody see for a while I was
getting told internet like everyone
should compliment men more because like
they don't hear very many compliment so
if you say like hey I like your shirt
like they'll remember that for the next
year yeah commented he's like the hot
chick in my high school told me that the
color of my sweater made my eyes pop and
my blue eyes you know come out I've worn
the same color sweater for the rest of
my life yeah that's the ugliest I feel
like women are very free with themselves
like to complement one another I love
your hair I love your shoes or whatever
and like I feel like that's not true for
men amongst yourselves maybe you are I
don't want to guys do the opposite but
guys rag on each other that's true I try
to compliment when it's genuine yeah
yeah but the thing about if a woman
compliments a guys the guy can take it
the wrong way and think that she wants
to have sex with them so you got to be
real careful yeah but not if though
men's like wow did you fix that computer
by yourself that's impressive
imagine just a guy walking down the
street a bunch of women are like oh damn
you're looking fine but like you're like
I feel pretty what's up what's your name
like like it would be so weird it would
be like but I wouldn't but what if it
was like a big fat old nasty woman in a
wheelchair and she's like come here and
give me some of that and I was just like
that's I'd still be flattered
I'd be like thank you like that's very
kind of you thank you
six big dudes are like you look good
like that's weird because they're bigger
than you there's a lot of them so I
think women do feel afraid a lot of
times when they get yelled at yeah but
yeah but look this comment is not is not
talking about overt harassment like a
guy pulls up in a Kong and starts saying
nasty things to a woman and just you
know like you got a big butt and that's
stupid that's the thing if like if if
there's that that video 10 hours of
walking through New York as a woman and
there were literally men saying like
good morning yeah and they were offended
by that it's unreal it's like okay dude
if you're offended by good morning we're
lost can't say anything yeah I think
that young women need a masculine source
of of strength in their life usually
that's the father if they don't have a
father that's why you know a strong
compliment can really help a human
regardless of their gender but things
getting sexual is just so weird I don't
know how to sexual is a it is a
compliment if a woman said sexual things
about a man like it would be
complimentary I would be flattered I
don't care how ugly you are I'd still
take it as a compliment it's cool the
first time from but like being I was in
Hollywood for a while and I started to
get overly sexualized it was real like I
just felt dirty and like a prostitute I
left it was it gets old let's read some
more Hollywood what's that West
Hollywood regular regular Hollywood all
right let's read this we got Gustav
Anderson it says Ian check out the
miracle of the Sun in Portugal 1917 you
might find it interesting
Ginny says 4 of the officers made bail
okay okay not the guy swinging probably
not the guy swinging I'm guessing yeah
all right let's uh let's see we get here
Maris McMullen says it's good to hear
that bocus is doing well unfortunately
none of us live forever I'm a woodturner
in Georgia who hand makes cremation urns
is there someone I could get in contact
with to give an earn for bocus I really
do appreciate it but it's Okay We're not
gonna do it
you know
we won't need it because everyone's
going to uh pray for bocus yeah I've
noticed with bucko he's uh he wants to
live and that's that's the key component
especially for a cat but for anyone
really so I'm giving him the tools that
I can to let his body do the work while
he gets what he desires you know what I
started doing I started heating up his
food and he eats it more because I'm
thinking about it and I'm like he yells
at me for food I put his kidney he's got
special kidney foot on the plate put it
down and then he looks at it and then he
sniffs it and then he just like walks
away
so I put in the microwave heat it up mix
it up a little bit put it on the ground
he goes right in nice I noticed uh if I
eat a piece of meat he wants it then I
feed him his meat he goes right for it
also if I read these you can't get any
of that now no just his phosphate meat
his lack of phosphere without phosphates
or um if I read the ingredients on his
food can and really pay attention to
what's in it he starts to get interest
in it and wants it like they want what
you want yeah maybe he's like hey don't
you mind some cats with kidney issues
like experience nausea so like part of
it is just making it appetizing for him
yeah we have these two different kinds
of kidney food and he like he goes back
and forth like first he liked one now he
won't touch it now he wants the other
one give him the chicken and pork liver
oh he was I tasted it I was like I could
survive off this Buckle I gotta be
honest like
I when I heated up his kidney food it
smelled like canned corned beef hash you
ever have that like Hormel or whatever
oh yeah I think so I like it it's a
little sweet I didn't take it I mean but
seriously in a survival situation man I
have eaten cat food before
I was gonna I got a five and a seven
year old want to get a pet I was gonna
wait for the dog until they get old
enough to walk him but then I'm thinking
I'm like I've never had a cat before
would you go cat with two kids like that
age I mean I had a cat when I was in the
third grade he lived for 17 years it was
the best thing ever I highly recommend
cats cats easy they seems you know how
to deal with them there's this guy
Jackson Galaxy who does a show well this
show called My Cat From Hell it's a TV
show you can watch watch those shows he
tells you everything you need to know
about how to live with a cat uh with
their litter box keeping it open to the
air with having shelves on the wall for
them to jump on to play with them to to
kind of mimic the hunt before you feed
them which mimics The Kill
there's a lot of ways it's very easy
cats are pretty independent and like
relative to dogs I I like dogs too
that's not that dogs are work dogs are
work and especially if you have kids in
the house like they're gonna learn to be
able to like clean up the litter box and
feed the cat like when you have a dog's
dog that needs the training it can be I
imagine dogs are part of like the
American dream yeah this is a weird
thing all right let's read this one from
owl night he says the latest project
Veritas video was removed that's right
James O'Keefe tweeting out that YouTube
took down the project driver does video
that's crazy he went to Twitter first
with it which is Twitter it's still up
20 million views yeah that's the way
it's like what's I mean what are they
trying to accomplish this still my guess
is that the people at alphabet or the
Google sensors or whoever was doing this
thought they're they're demonizing this
guy uh Jared is that his name Jared the
dude that's like don't Jared with an o
or something I don't want a mistake
Jordan Jordan
that they might think that this is
actually abusing towards this guy like
it's getting the point where people are
hating on the sky and these kind of
abuse but like let's just stay focused
on what statistical criminality and that
Marco Rubio sent a letter to the CEO of
Pfizer like yo explain this
whatever happens with Jordan you know
let's be kind to the guy I understand
not wanting to like
I don't know put something that's just
like degrading to a human being I do
think that like everything James O'Keefe
did like the way he conducts himself
seems fair it's not like he himself is
like it's different if it's a video
where he's walking up being like you're
an idiot like you know what I mean that
obviously is not what the video was
everybody follow at timcast news on
Twitter because we've got videos coming
out of the let's just say burgeoning
riot in New York city so I say that
because a lot of it is protest but
they've they smashed up a you know a guy
jumped on a police car smashed the
windshield we've got footage of it with
the police running the vehicle so it's
getting to that point where it's pushing
towards Riot territory
so uh at timcast news on Twitter we got
a reporter on the ground I believe it's
uh yeah he's out there he's on the
ground yeah okay yeah
all right
Lyon says 25 States filed the lawsuit
yesterday in federal court to stop the
Biden Administration from allowing your
employer to invest your retirement
Savings in ESG it may be the most
important case this year wow
okay that's cool vague though invest in
ESG by that do you mean invest in things
that support BlackRock
I think just companies that have like
ESG scores who knows what it means
exactly all right
David's C Cronk senior says it was a no
win scenario no matter what Paul Pelosi
did he could spill his drink that's an
alcohol that's alcohol abuse
I mean it's weird he wouldn't let that
drink go he could have dropped the drink
and then grabbed with his other hand he
didn't know he's like no not my drink it
reminds me of South Park when uh
what's Jimbo is that his name is
teaching the kids how to hunt and then
they're like you know he's that's like a
misfire like whoa that was dangerous he
almost spilled your beer yeah yeah I'd
like to call him diving after the One
Ring yeah
Pelosi diving for the drink jeez man
all right
ready to rumble says it's clearly a
hostage situation with an elderly man
how is this hard to understand yeah I'm
with you because
what we assume or expect from a hot
situation is not what happened it's as
simple as that
it doesn't make sense that depap would
be standing with him while he called the
police said I don't want police but are
the Capitol Police there
now I've gotta gotta get off the phone I
just it doesn't add up yeah I don't know
man I'm not I'm not saying I'm I'm
insinuating something happened I'm just
saying quite literally this seems weird
to me it's an example of Madness in
action it could be a crazy guy he said
could be a crazy guy you know crazy guy
it it uh it does seem like you're you're
stretching to cover all of the weird
things about it but you know maybe
that's the reality huh
all right what do we got here
Eddie F says Tim don't forget your rule
make making the least amount of
assumptions this is all staged and
they're all Bad actors things got out of
hand in the end because they involved
drugs and alcohol and that makes too
many assumptions though you'd have to
assume that they planned something and
there were meanings beforehand The
Simple Solution is well I'm sorry this
is tough so the Pelosi's had no security
on their house this one night and that's
when the guy decided to come was he
staking it out like I just got so many
questions about this once I saw him
smashing the window with a hammer David
to Pap I I it set my mind at ease about
what happened I think he did I did ask
why there's no alarm yeah there's no I
mean I guess he's home so maybe he
didn't set it like it as much as like it
kind of explains what happens like there
are still questions it's not definitive
by any means like it's just weird that
he's that accessible like yeah I can
just go in Nancy Pelosi's house right it
doesn't make sense or like like Tim said
like this is the one night there wasn't
security like no we have armed security
guards yeah there's no Capital he said
there's no Capital police outside
usually he said usually they're Capital
police outside the building protecting
my wife but like she was in DC right so
like is he trying to say normally like
normally my house is heavily secured but
please come help me because tonight it's
not like yeah I don't know it doesn't I
went to CPAC and I couldn't get near
Josh Holly like he's got like he's like
good luck getting near him you know but
I can just walk in Nancy Pelosi's house
whenever I want that's wild I was
driving back from New York yesterday or
in the car and I looked I was just
looking at houses as we were driving on
the road and like the windows I could
see into their living room I could see
the TV and I'm like we live in such a
luxurious Society where you can have
your freaking house glass windows
leading into where you sleep at night
like it's glass
as a South African it's the weirdest
thing it's like you guys trust that
David R says the dispatch call can be
explained simply he introduced himself
as a Pelosi in the dispatcher voted for
Trump solves every question
I mean hey the cop more likely to be
Republican but no I think the dispatcher
was just a little
what's the right word without being mean
RMV lady slow on the uptake
yeah I don't think she follows National
politics no I just mean like when he's
like there's a guy in my house who just
came in and I have a problem she's like
well call me back if anything happens
it's like okay
is she not trained
yeah Wayne now says the times don't make
sense 911 call was at 2 25 a.m video of
him breaking in is at 5 31 a.m and body
camera video footage is at 9 31 am but
we know it wasn't at 9 31 in the morning
like that's not when the cop showed up
no but that's what I was talking about
as I saw that Super Chat earlier and I
was wondering why um on all these on all
these things we don't see any particular
time frames exactly when this happened
there's no you normally when something
like this happens you have an instant
report of like all the time frames going
down but with this we've never seen
anything saying this happened this time
this happened this time this happened
this time
chronologically like listed it hasn't
happened yet so it is weird it says 931
on the body camera footage but it's
certainly not 931 it's dark out yeah
that's what I'm saying like it's clearly
not 931. the argument that like the
Legacy Media I mean they're like TC
there were like a bunch of uh
Publications that like sued to get this
this stuff released and they said all of
this has been read in Pre pre-trial
evidence hearing so like theoretically a
report like that search would have come
out then too and maybe they just include
a lawsuit like would UTC make sense if
it's nine that would put it at like
midnight or something though wouldn't it
or one one A.M 131 no but the call the
call was at two two in the morning so
the police had to respond sometime after
that so around three so why'd it says
609 31. UTC is separish it's nine
Universal yeah so that's it's three
minus five hours ahead of east coast of
us yeah which means it would be eight
for Los Angeles so that would put us at
1 31 am but the phone call was made
around 2 A.M 2 25 a.m so it's an hour
later yeah so it doesn't make it doesn't
make sense maybe unless like daylight
savings daylight savings with a 9 pm oh
yeah we're not in daylight savings
though it's minus five right now daily
it's it's after March it goes to minus
four doesn't it God I don't know I heard
they're thinking about getting rid of
that daylight savings yeah sure I always
talk about it every year yeah yeah well
anyway let's read some more Super chats
yep
all right
Franco Phillips says Tim and friends the
reason that our government wants to
abolish the police is that they can
instill a Gestapo federal police system
when the citizens begged for them back
that is a very astute thing to point out
I agree that if we ever were to get rid
of local police you're left with federal
police or private police and you don't
want those to run your life trust me
I've seen it in Chile just even when
they were on my side it was
disconcerting to see federalis on the
corner with their guns and stuff I mean
you guys watch Walking Dead I mean
that's basically what happens in a
lawless Society it's like you're gonna
get the negan's you're going to the
saviors like that's why that shows
someone realistic it's like this is what
happens when a society breaks down the
guy with the bat with the barbed wire on
it who kills one person every time he
comes to a new Village he's in charge
now like that's what you're going to get
instead of the police so think think of
it twice before you abolish them think
about what comes next because they never
do yeah if you look at South Africa as
well we have like private security all
over the country and it's not
necessarily a better system I'll tell
you that right now was it worse I mean
I'd say it's worse because the thing is
it's private security they're they hold
you till they get to the police it
doesn't really it's not exactly the same
thing as like a police service that is
like beholden to the law et cetera et
cetera you might just beat people up uh
I wouldn't say it's like not like that
but you know they don't like if they did
you know there's no body cams on them
Casino police bringing you in the back
room right pitch account cards exactly
you can't you can't hold them
accountable to anything so that's the
thing that's that's it's not like you
said it's not necessarily better you get
the Negan guy um I barely watch that
series but I know what you're talking
about I understand it's Lawless it's not
the same it's not a better system just
because you abolish the police doesn't
mean that bad guys stop doesn't mean
that people aren't going to steal your
stuff doesn't mean people forget that
they don't think about that the time
stamp on the break-in footage is 5 am
so are these just clocks that are all
set wrong is that what it is I mean
that's that's a possibility I don't know
man it's weird I mean the the issue I
take with it is
sure
but once you start stacking up all these
weird things you are now looking at
it's like
you do not have it's a Jenga Tower full
of holes you know I mean it's not a
strongly supported structure of this
narrative when it's like all these
pieces you take out one piece and it's
like time stamp 5 a.m and you go yeah
well you know the cameras could be off
yeah and then it's like okay body camera
footage 9am well I guess the body camera
footage then you pull out another one
phone call 2AM okay none of the time
stamps add up putting a bunch of holes
in the narrative
then there's the phone call is this the
police yeah oops it was a mistake in the
place I don't I don't think so but are
the Capitol Police there
why there's so many holes and the tower
is about to fall down whoever's making
that Next Movement taking them to Capcom
he called the cops then to Pap left and
came back later with a hammer at 5am and
then they set off an alarm silent alarm
and then the cops came out and that's
what we saw I'm wondering I have no idea
these conversations are taking place
yeah like like CNN the immediate thing
is going to be like this is somehow
Trump's fault like that's somehow they
will spin it we got a good one here
Highlander Ultra says red pilled my mom
today the News Guard rating for MSNBC
and Obama sipping water at Flint
Michigan if alcohol is at the coffee
shops a keto biscuit would be a good
pairing Myrtle Beach SC will have you
um I'm telling you guys get News Guard
and I know a lot of conservative work
I'm not supporting news gun I'm like no
no hear me out use the tools you have to
win your arguments News Guard rates
MSNBC as essentially fake news as they
do not adhere to journalistic standards
you can then tell your wine Aunt your
uncles your your woke friends and family
and you don't get aggressive with them
and say you watch fake news look I can
prove it you say where did where did you
hear that you're not watching that
conspiracy stuff what MSNBC is out that
is that the Rachel maddowell you should
like she's like lady Alex Jones or
whatever and then they're like what
that's not true like yeah yeah here look
look good news guard yeah C says fake
news is that what you're watching and
they'll go
oh wow how do you respond to that but
then won't Politico say that News Guard
is in and of itself fake news no that's
a right wing thing but news God gives
Politico a perfect score oh okay yeah
who's really in control
okay they're like okay look we get we we
should have a perfect score but News
Guard wrongly dinged us for no reason
because they're full of the full they're
full of it what was the ding they said
that we quoted Donald Trump and that
Trump was wrong therefore we were wrong
and we were like the story we ran was
Donald Trump says thing it's a news
thing that happened like we should have
fact checked him and I said we're not
running an analysis on what Donald Trump
said we're reporting him having said
that and we only did it I think five
times in the years the the couple years
that's been up out of 4 000 articles
there were five instances and they said
that warrants you being irresponsible
news producers ethical question as you
start your fact checking service with
your charity Foundation are you gonna
fact check yourself Tim kiss yeah that's
the one of the principal purposes so the
I ideas to not have them work in the
same place or be in communication
but then to grab the Articles go through
them and then ding them but here's my
attitude the the fact checking plan that
we have is we randomly sample 100
articles from the past three months or
something like that
we then do a check for journalistic
ethics minimizing harm facts things like
that if they violate any ethic we will
we will we create a spreadsheet showing
the X explaining the violation and then
giving them a score X Out Of 100. The
New York Times I think would probably
end up at like a 70 out of 100 and we'd
have 30 articles saying like here's why
we believe this violated standard ethics
however
if the New York Times then goes in and
addresses that and removes the violation
we will then change it to a check and
say a correction has been made the New
York Times corrected this and removed
the violation and improved their score
so the real Trail of the error and the
correction all in this yeah the idea
would be like you can see everything
they've done
so that would mean for timcast well
absolutely we they should be checking us
too because then the benefit is when
they come and say we randomly sampled
100 articles and we found you know 35
were violating these ethics that's a low
score we'd be like we'll have our team
going and correct each and every one of
these things I like it we need more
people that investigate themselves and
find something wrong but it's but the
idea is great it's an independent
they're not going to work in The
Newsroom with the news team they're
going to be outside yeah so we will have
active fact Checkers double fact
checking our articles we will then use
that to correct any mistakes we make
from from the fact Checkers and then we
will create a browser extension that
will do the exact same thing for every
other Outlet takes a long time it'll be
very difficult but if you can use AI
something like a chat sheet no that's
not so easy
like how do you how do you AI minimize
harm
that's tough so when when CNN said this
guy made a meme we will reveal his
identity unless he stops making memes
we'd be like X I mean that warrants a
failing grade I don't know man there's
also
I'm I'm wondering if we give a you know
zero out of 100 to any overt and
egregious acts of evil like that CNN
thing like this is not a credible news
agency they have used their weight on
more than one occasion to threaten
people's lives like livelihoods sorry
I'm Andrew Kaczynski won with the right
WWE oh yeah there were other there were
other instances too and and going to
that old lady's house who was like on
Facebook right those are such a
courageous violations of journalistic
standards
you know like yeah that's an Ethics
thing James O'Keefe going to an
executive's house is like well you know
and asking him questions it's like
that's what I mean by holding the power
like the media does not go after the
powerful they go after the power less
and when you go after the powerful that
is when you get in trouble and it's kind
of like what I do I mean it's my own
business models going after the powerful
and you see what happens when they do
they don't like that all right John
McGee says how many people know who the
president pro tempore of the Senate is
or what the person's role is where do
they fall in the presidential line of
succession how about who is the
president of the Senate that's all just
so very funny isn't it I don't know
either of those things so uh who who is
currently president pro temporary it's
uh it's it's not still grassly after
this is that the same thing as uh I
think it's Grassley
I'm looking at it now anyone else any
other guesses it is it was grasslands
now it's Patty Murray oh since January
3rd 2023. that's why I was asking yeah
it just changed it was grass is this
thing where like I use that term when I
cover grassly enough but like now that
we've switched over and everyone shifted
like catch me again in four months I
probably can't answer all of them but
you get better but again this is like my
job like I get to read and study this
all the time right now
I'm pretty sure okay when I was like
playing a lot of Madden 2003 you know
back in the day uh I knew all I was
learning all the players I knew all
their names I knew their their speeds I
knew how their their stats for a little
while touchdowns they threw yeah I was I
was covering uh when every state like
for a while starting like November 30th
a bunch of states started Banning tick
tock on like government platforms and on
government networks and stuff and so I
found this very interesting and covered
intensely for the site and so at one
point I was like listing I could name
every governor of like all of these
states who had done this because I was
using that information so readily like
if if you're a student in your 11th
grade history class I'm sure they're all
like ready to explain what everything in
the constitution is it's just how how
often are you accessing this information
how often do you have to use it and they
change the positions change just like
football if you're out of it for five
years you know there's new players if
you're not regularly teaching history
you're not going to remember I mean
you're going to forget 95 of what I
taught you I would never expect my
students to remember like remember I
taught you this lesson unless you're
actively involved in it every day you
know there's only so much information
your brain can retain I call it mental
bandwidth I've heard that from someone
else but when people ask me hey do you
want to do this instead of saying I
can't I just say I don't have the mental
bandwidth for it yeah I use that
expression too I don't have bandwidth
for this like I think about that all the
time with people who are working you
know not in the news industry and have
children and have you know things going
on in their life like I have a I've had
people say to me like oh I just feel
like I haven't checked the news in weeks
and they probably haven't but not
because they're bad people because they
have other things uh other demands on
their time right like we have to have
Grace for people who don't have the time
to look at the news all the time I
that's why I feel like what we get to do
with Tim cast is cool because it's like
hey if you have five minutes to scroll
through Twitter or to check our website
like here are some stuff that like would
be good that might affect your life that
would be good for you no going forward
like you don't have to be an expert all
the time and that's why we say become a
member of timcast.com so we can do a lot
more of that let's grab we got a couple
more good super chats here Cameron Peter
says project Veritas has posted that
Jordan Walker is still an active
employee proving he wasn't a contractor
very interesting and then uh last one
right here this is great Viper Says hey
just want to thank you Tim and Luke you
guys gave me the inspiration to eat
better and I'm already seeing results
you guys are doing a great job with info
you and I find really helps is uh
actually a scale
so when uh not this past November of the
number November before the October
actually before I got covered I was
about 200 pounds and uh I didn't care
yeah it literally just didn't care and I
I ate what I felt like eating and just
did what I feel felt like doing and then
one day I just stopped eating sugar and
then decided just you know what I'm
gonna cut all those sugars out and then
start losing weight really quickly
check the scale abruptly like after a
week or two and I was like oh damn I was
down like five pounds
then the next day I would hit the scale
I'm down again and then every day I go
down what happens is when I get back on
the scale I start going up I'm like oh
and then it makes me think about it all
day that's just me I don't know if it
works for anybody else but then I'm like
whoop I ate that that Pazuki over at
BJ's Brewhouse and now I'm feeling it
those are so good though have you guys
ever been there no yeah yeah of course
yeah I've been there it's a it's a
cookie baked into a little pan ice cream
big ice cream on top I'm not addicted to
sugar right now Oreo one has got Oreo
cream filling on top yeah you weighed
200 pounds yeah imagine that yeah yeah I
can't look at the videos look at look at
watch the show you said that like you
had an outro at the end of your videos
and what you came in here like we gotta
reshoot that I don't look like that
anymore well no no people commented
someone's super someone super chatted
your your outro video is you're fatter
you can tell you lost weight dude it's
the John Stossel thumbnail of your
interview right like a year ago that's
the most obvious yeah Brown puffy
compared to what you are now I feel like
I can't tell it's seeing you every day
yeah I was gonna say like you said that
once like oh yeah I was 200 pounds and I
remember being like what really oh yeah
because like the other thing is like you
also implemented like doing something
you love skating and being active I was
I was skating then too yeah but we were
getting Hibachi and I'd have a big bowl
of rice yeah but like making several
small changes like they are difficult at
first but they actually do pay off over
time and I think you are you know
someone who who did that right you cut
sugar first I also think I accidentally
stopped eating a lot I just kind of
that's good that fasting thing's Key
Well Luke if you guys saw I think it was
on his Instagram a picture of him with
the eggs being like acting like a coupon
mode with his cocaine but he looks
ripped dude he's got the turtle I'm like
does he have that fake bodysuit that's
Luke's chest and then I got real
emasculated I was like I gotta start
working out he's trying to get you to
work out the guy he's a beast dude he
went full beast mode in like two months
he got all this muscle definition he's
been having the trainer come and do the
work with him yeah all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
cut out the sugars start eating healthy
start exercising you'll you'll really
appreciate it because I can't even begin
to explain first I would say find a
personal trainer a nutritionist or
whatever you can or start researching it
find out what makes sense for you
because not everybody's the same but uh
I gotta tell you this when you get in
shape you'll all of a sudden just feel
so good and it's really hard to describe
when you are out of shape you don't
realize you feel bad and then like once
I stopped I cut out the garbage it feels
like I wake up in the morning like a
surge of lightning just like I used to
wake up like now I wake up like oh yeah
and and I can tell when I eat garbage
because like I'm not I'm not telling
people to be monks you know I had a
Pazuki Okay cookie ice cream all over it
but I mostly cut it out and I make it
really like a rare treat although the
past week I was just like I had like
three days in a row because I was
feeling miserable but I tell you this I
learned my lesson because I wake up in
the morning like I feel miserable and
then I'm like okay and then I had tuna
salad yesterday only thing I ate tuna
salad with peppers Allison cooked it was
fantastic and the next day I woke up
feeling like I could punch through a
brick wall it was it was incredible so
do it by yourself become a member at
timcast.com if you want to support our
work our journalists the the cultural
Endeavors the fact checking stuff it all
takes time but we are working on all
this stuff the cafe is currently under
design in production we own the building
it is happening now we have to do
construction I don't know how long it
could take but it is a relatively new
project so you can follow the show at
Tim castirally you can follow me
personally at timcast Turtle boy you
want to shout anything out yeah just
shout out to all the turtle Riders I see
your turtle emojis in the comments
thanks for showing up if anybody wants
to follow me I'm at Dr Turtle Boy docto
our turtle boy because of Jill Biden's a
doctor I'm definitely a doctor and our
website is tbdailynews.com thank you for
having me it's a real pleasure being
here yeah absolutely it's a blast uh I'm
Hannah Claire I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should follow timcast
news I know Tim already said it but we
have some uh on the ground footage going
up from New York tonight uh at timcast
news on Twitter I'm being coached on how
to talk about something I was in the at
symbol with my handsome we could do
charades it's okay we should yeah so at
timcast news on Twitter definitely go
there especially tonight you can follow
me on Instagram at Hannah claire.be or
and you can follow me on Twitter at HC
brimlow yeah guys thanks so much I'm at
Ian Crossland anywhere you want to find
me it's probably going to be me check
for the long hair and uh you take the
risk if there's something you want to do
do it if you want to make a company
right now you start that company we are
we documenting the bocus yeah we did we
have a bunch of good doc early
documentary stuff I want to do an
interview with the Doctor Who's super
cool uh Hospital Hopewell Animal
Hospital thank you guys so much for
everything you've done so far
um you've been just amazing to bucko to
meet the staff you guys are fantastic
I'm looking forward I think it's
actually really interesting because this
is experimental and if it works
yeah and we have documented this process
because this could be it could it could
lead to this process becoming cheaper
more affordable kidney failure could be
a thing of the past for these animals
this is one of the leading leads cause
of death for dogs and cats so that could
be to the point where we could eradicate
that kind of thing you look at people
healing the blind healing deaf people
are able to hear now healing spinal cord
injuries with graphene insertions I mean
we are on the precipice of magic in real
time so take the risk like I did taking
that cat for for 10 hours and I do it
all again 50 more times and uh you would
be amazed at the results
thank you and I am at surge.com uh I
hope elod stays safe on the ground there
in New York that's who's reporting I
imagine right yeah it's a lot okay and
uh yeah I hope you guys have a good
weekend be good to be back next week I'm
at surge.com everywhere Twitter
Instagram follow me wherever you want to
see me
it was a good show yeah all right thanks
for hanging out everybody I hope you
enjoy the weekend we'll be back with
Clips throughout tomorrow and and Sunday
we have clips from all throughout the
week you can check out more content at
timcast.com and then we'll see you all
again Monday cheers